OKAY. ALL RIGHT. LET'S GET
STARTED HERE WITH OUR SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE,
BUT WE DO HAVE 13 BILLS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY. AND I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE A TON OF PLACES.
THEY ALL NEED TO BE. SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE THROUGH AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN. WE'LL COME BACK AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AS SOON AS
THAT IS POSSIBLE FOR US. BUT WE
DO HAVE SENATOR LAIRD HERE. SO,
SENATOR LAIRD, WOULD YOU PLEASE
START US OFF? THAT'D BE OKAY.
WELCOME THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1064. IT'S A BILL
THAT AIMS TO MODERNIZE THE STATE
LICENSING STRUCTURE FOR CANNABIS
. THE BILL REPRESENTS A CRUCIAL
STEP FORWARD IN ACHIEVING Kò
OBJECTIVES TO HELP TO SUPPORT
THE STATE'S LEGAL AND REGULATED
INDUSTRY. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR THE
THOROUGH ANALYSIS, AND OUR GOAL
IS TO MODERNIZE THE CURRENT
LICENSING STRUCTURE AND NOT
CREATE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES,
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROLS, 2003 ANNUAL
REPORT, AND THESE ARE CITED IN
THE ANALYSIS, THE PROCESSING
TIMES FOR THE CURRENT DIFFERENT
LICENSES ARE FOR CULTIVATION 221
DAYS FOR MANUFACTURING, 180 DAYS
FOR DISTRIBUTION, 287 DAYS FOR
TESTING LABORATORY LICENSES, 851
DAYS FOR RETAILER LICENSES, 183
DAYS FOR MICROBUSINESS LICENSES,
244 DAYS FOR EVENT ORGANIZED
LICENSES, 153 DAYS, AND FOR JUST
A TEMPORARY CANNABIS EVENT
LICENSE. IT'S 59 DAYS. THESE ARE
MANY TIMES PEOPLE HAVE TO APPLY
FOR MULTIPLE ONES IN HOWEVER
THEY DO IT. THE SYSTEM IS
CUMBERSOME AND IT IS JUST NOT
WORKING. AND SO IT'S OUR GOAL
WITH THE BILL THAT THESE TIMES
CAN BE REDUCED, WHICH IS A
BENEFIT FOR THE APPLICANT, A
SAVING THEM TIME AND MONEY. AND
IT'S A BENEFIT FOR THE STATE AND
LOCAL JURISDICTION. AND IT GIVES
CERTAINTY FOR BOTH THE
APPLICANT, THE GOVERNING
AUTHORITY AND THE PUBLIC IN WHAT
TO EXPECT AND MINIMIZES THE
PLACES THAT THEY HAVE TO
INTERFACE TO DEAL WITH THESE
ISSUES. AND IT FURTHER CLARIFIES
THE ROLE OF STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE LICENSING AND
OVERSIGHT OF CANNABIS BUSINESSES
, ELIMINATING DUPLICATION. AND I
WANT TO RESPOND TO FOUR SPECIFIC
SUGGESTIONS THAT WERE IN THE
ANALYSIS. CGRTS, IT STATES THE
AUTHOR SHOULD CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
THAT ANY CHANGES TO THE CURRENT
REGULATORY STRUCTURE DO NOT HAVE
UNINTENDED LEGISLATIVE
CHALLENGES. LATER. I COMMIT TO
DOING THAT, THE AUTHOR SHOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS ANY
NECESSARY TECHNICAL CHANGES. I
COMMIT TO DOING THAT. THE AUTHOR
SHOULD CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN REVISING
PROVISIONS OF PROPOSITION 64. I
COMMIT TO DOING THAT, AND THE
AUTHOR SHOULD CONSIDER EXTENDING
THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE UPON
CONSULTATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF CANNABIS CONTROL, DCC I'M
FOLLOWING MY OWN THING ABOUT
DEFINING THE ACRONYM BEFORE YOU
USE IT TO ENSURE A SMOOTH AND
SUCCESSFUL LICENSING TRANSITION,
I WILL CONSULT WITH THEM AND SEE
IF THAT WORKS WITH ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS AND IS POSSIBLE.
AND SO THERE ARE LOTS OF WHEN
YOU READ THE ANALYSIS, IT JUST
LOOKS VERY COMPLEX BECAUSE IT
LOOKS LIKE, WELL, YOU'RE
CHANGING THIS, YOU'RE DOING
THIS. IF YOU'RE REALLY TRYING TO
CONSOLIDATE INTO THE TWO
CATEGORIES OF LICENSE AND YOU'RE
TRYING TO DEFINE CLEAR THE
ROLES, THAT'S WHY IT LOOKS
COMPLEX. BUT IT IS WITH THOSE
GOALS IN MIND. AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO COMMIT TO THE
THINGS THAT WERE OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS, WHICH WE WILL DO, THE
LICENSING REFORM FRAMEWORK
WITHIN THIS BILL WAS DEVELOPED
FROM RECOMMENDATIONS WITHIN THE
RECENT CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
REPORT, LICENSING AND MARKET
ACCESS, PUBLISHED BY THE
CANNABIS POLICY LAB. THERE IS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION AT THIS
POINT. GREAT, MY WITNESSES WERE
STUCK IN THE LONG LINE OUTSIDE,
SO AT LEAST ONE OF THEM HAS
ARRIVED HERE. BOTH. OKAY. SO
WELCOME, JOINING ME IN SUPPORT
IS CHRISTINA DEMPSEY WITH THE
CANNABIS POLICY LAB AND SARAH
DUQUETTE, ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM, I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL. GREAT.
AND WELCOME TO YOU, TOO. YOU'LL
EACH GET TWO MINUTES. THANKS FOR
BRAVING THE SWING SPACE
ELEVATORS TO JOIN US TODAY.
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS SARAH
DUQUETTE WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA, A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON THIS
BILL. WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
IDEAS TO MAKE THIS A STREAMLINED
PROCESS, AND THAT'S HOW WE,
REALLY WORKED ON THESE IDEAS.
AND ONE OF THE KEY POINTS THAT
I'D LIKE TO BRING UP IS THE LACK
OF KIND OF CLARITY BETWEEN THE
STATE ROLE AND THE LOCAL ROLES.
WHEN THIS LICENSING SCHEME
STARTED, WE WERE DOING DUAL
LICENSING. RIGHT. LOCALS ARE
TRYING TO COME ON BOARD WITH THE
STATE, TRYING TO COME ON BOARD,
WHICH RESULTED IN A LOT OF THE
SAME WORK BEING DONE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND THE STATE LEVEL.
SO THIS REALLY SPLITS UP THE
LICENSING INTO THREE PARTS. ONE
IS THE INITIAL OPERATOR LICENSE,
AND THAT'S WHERE THE APPLICANT
IS FULLY VETTED. SO BY THE TIME
THEY GET TO A LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
THEY HAVE THEIR STATE LICENSE.
THEY CAN OPERATE. THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH THEIR BACKGROUND CHECK,
THEY'VE BEEN VETTED, THEY COMPLY
WITH THE STATE LAW AND THEN IT
MAKES IT EASIER FOR US LOCALS TO
KNOW WHO THEY ARE. AND THEN WE
HAVE THAT ROLE OF THE LAND USE,
THE SITE SPECIFIC LOCATION
REVIEW. AND THEN ONCE THEY MAKE
IT THROUGH THAT, THEY GO BACK TO
THE STATE FOR THAT FINAL
PROCESS, WHICH IS REALLY A
LICENSING THE PREMISE, WHICH IS
THE ACTUAL ACTIVITY GOING ON AT
THAT LOCATION, WHICH THEY'RE THE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS ON. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS NEW FRAMEWORK
WILL ALLOW THOSE ROLES TO BE
REALLY CLEAR. IT WOULD ALSO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF WORK LOCALS
ARE DOING THAT'S DUPLICATIVE OF
THE STATE. AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL
BE ABLE TO GET FOLKS THROUGH A
LOT QUICKER. AND ALSO FOR
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVEN'T MADE
THAT STEP FORWARD AND REALLY
ALLOWING A RETAIL OR CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES ALLOW THEM TO KIND OF
HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING THEMSELVES
INTO. OH, OKAY. SO IT'S ZONING
CODE, IT'S GENERAL PLAN, IT'S
LAND USE. I DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT ALL THESE OTHER THINGS.
THEY COME TO ME FULLY VETTED
THEIR LICENSED AND READY TO GO.
SO WE DO THINK THAT WE WILL SEE
AN IMPROVEMENT ON THOSE, COMING
ON BOARD AND ALLOWING ACTIVITIES
LIKE RETAIL. WITH THAT, I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE.
THIS ONE. OKAY. GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA DEMPSEY, AND I'M THE
FOUNDER OF THE CANNABIS POLICY
LAB. WE ARE A NONPARTISAN,
RESEARCH BASED ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS IN
THE DEVELOPMENT AND REFINEMENT
OF CANNABIS POLICY. I WORKED FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE CANNABIS
PROGRAMS FOR NEARLY SIX YEARS,
FROM 2017 UNTIL 2023. I HELPED
STAND UP THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH'S CANNABIS
PROGRAM, SERVED ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROLS
INITIAL EXECUTIVE TEAM, AND
ENDED MY SERVICE AS THE FIRST
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. AFTER I LEFT THE
DEPARTMENT, I SPENT FOUR MONTHS
TALKING TO STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
HOW THE STATUTES COULD BE
IMPROVED. ONE OF THE RECURRING
ISSUES RAISED IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IS HOW INEFFICIENT
THE LICENSING PROCESS IS.
BUSINESSES ARE OFTEN REVIEWED
FOR THE SAME CRITERIA AT THE
LOCAL AND STATE LEVELS. AS SARAH
WAS DESCRIBING, AND BECAUSE A
SEPARATE STATE LICENSE IS
REQUIRED FOR EACH ACTIVITY
CONDUCTED, THE LEGAL BUSINESS
ENTITY AND ITS FINANCIAL PARTIES
ARE SOMETIMES REVIEWED BY THE
STATE AND MULTIPLE TIMES. THIS
DUPLICATION INCREASES
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR
GOVERNMENT AND MAKES CITIES AND
COUNTIES HESITANT TO CREATE
CANNABIS PERMITTING PROGRAMS.
IT'S CONFUSING FOR BUSINESSES
WHO OFTEN HAVE TO SUBMIT THE
SAME INFORMATION MULTIPLE TIMES
TO DIFFERENT LAYERS OF
GOVERNMENT OR TO DIFFERENT STATE
ANALYSTS. SB 1064 IS A
SUBSTANTIAL EFFORT TO REIMAGINE
WHAT AN IMPROVED CANNABIS
LICENSING PROCESS COULD LOOK
LIKE BY ALLOWING THE STATE TO
ISSUE OPERATOR LICENSES
SEPARATELY FROM THE LOCATION
LICENSE, IT WOULD CREATE A
SINGLE STATE REVIEW OF THE
BUSINESS ENTITY AND ITS OWNERS,
ELIMINATING REPETITIVE REVIEWS.
SB 1064 REQUIRES THE STATE TO
ESTABLISH SPECIFIC CRITERIA FOR
REVIEWING A PROPOSED LOCATION
FOR THE BUSINESS TO OPERATE, AND
TO CONDUCT ITS REVIEW.
MINISTERIALLY. THIS ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DECIDE THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF A SITE
LOCATION WITHIN THE COMMUNITY,
ALIGNING WITH THEIR EXPERTISE IN
TIME, PLACE AND MANNER, AND IT
ALLOWS THE STATE TO FOCUS ITS
REVIEW ON WHETHER THE APPLICANTS
ARE ELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE MARKET. ALIGNING WITH THEIR
ROLE OF SETTING STATEWIDE
MARKETPLACE STANDARDS. SB 1064
IS A MEANINGFUL STEP FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING THE UNNECESSARY
DUPLICATION AND COMPLEXITY IN
THE CANNABIS LICENSING PROCESS,
AND IN REMOVING THE BARRIERS.
GIVE US YOUR FINAL THOUGHT.
THERE AND IN REMOVING THE
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT BUSINESSES
FROM BECOMING LEGAL OPERATORS.
ALL RIGHT. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ARE THERE OTHERS IN THE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO JOIN IN
ME TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1064? NOW WOULD BE THE TIME.
YES. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN. MEMBERS AMY JENKINS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALICIA PRIEGO HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AND
ALSO KIVA CONFECTIONS IN SUPPORT
. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, SAM
RODRIGUEZ, ON BEHALF OF GOOD
FARMERS, GOOD NEIGHBORS BASED IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY, WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND WE ALSO WANT
TO APPLAUD SENATOR JOHN LAIRD,
HIS EXPERIENCE IN LOCAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENT AND EXECUTIVE
BRANCH IS THE RIGHT PERSON FOR
THE RIGHT TIME FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, JARED
KILO, ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
CANNABIS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION,
WHO REPRESENTS HUNDREDS OF
RETAILERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND STRONG SUPPORT. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. THAT'S IT FOR, TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT. GREAT. THEN DO WE
HAVE OPPOSITION? AND IF THERE'S
LEAD OPPOSITION, YOU CAN COME ON
FORWARD. WE'LL GIVE YOU A COUPLE
MINUTES SEEING NONE. ARE THERE
FOLKS? WHO WOULD LIKE TO JUST
COMMENT AS ME TO OPPOSITION,
SEEING NONE IN THE ROOM. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
SENATOR ARCHULETA, THANK YOU,
SENATOR, FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I THOUGHT THIS HAD TO
DO WITH JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING IN
GOVERNMENT, BUT BUT I GUESS
WE'RE JUST FOCUSING ON ON THIS
INDUSTRY, AND I'M JOSHING
BECAUSE, THERE'S SO MANY THINGS
THAT HAVE THE SAME ISSUE. BUT
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 16
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES, LET ME
HAVE YOU ADDRESS THAT. FIRST OF
ALL, IF YOU HAVE 16 DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES, I WOULD THINK IF YOU
WERE ABLE TO CONDENSE IT, IT
WOULD BE CULTIVATION. I WOULD
THINK, OF COURSE TRANSPORTATION
WOULD BE ONE ANOTHER MIGHT BE
THE RETAIL SALES, BUT FROM 16
DOWN TO TWO. BUT I THINK, YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT
BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CULTIVATION, AND CERTAINLY THE
TRANSPORTATION AND OF COURSE THE
TESTING AND THE RETAIL. THAT
WOULD BE MY FOUR, THAT SOMETHING
HASN'T BEEN IN THE VETTING THAT
TAKES PLACE. THEN YOU GET BACK
OVER HERE TO THE OTHER SIDE OF
851 DAYS, TO GET A LICENSE FOR
TESTING. SO WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY A
CRUCIAL PART OF ALL THIS, BUT
YET THE TEMPORARY IS 59 DAYS. SO
WHAT KIND OF A TIME FRAME WOULD
BE LOOKING AT IF YOU ARE ABLE TO
GET THIS THING THROUGH AND GET
IT DONE AT THE OTHER END, THERE
WERE A LOT OF QUESTIONS IN
THERE. AND SO LET ME TRY IN A
SIMPLE WAY TO DO IT. AND I
BELIEVE THE FIRST WITNESS REALLY
LINED IT OUT. AND IF YOU'RE
REALLY TRYING TO DO, YOU, IT'S
CATEGORIZED DIFFERENTLY THAN YOU
JUST CATEGORIZED TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS EVERY ISSUE THAT YOU
JUST LISTED, SO THAT IF YOU HAVE
OF A VETTING OF THE APPLICANT,
THEN YOU HAVE THE LOCAL
PERMITTING PROCESS, AND THEN YOU
HAVE THE STATE PART, YOU'RE
CONSOLIDATING ALL THE DIFFERENT
THINGS IN THAT. AND THAT WAY IF
THERE'S TRANSPORT STATION AND
THAT'S A SITE ISSUE, THE LOCALS
DEAL WITH IT IN CERTAIN PIECES
OF CULTIVATION. IT'S LOCAL
ISSUES AND IT'S DEALT WITH
THERE. THE PERSON'S VETTED
BEFORE THE STATE ISSUES ARE
DEALT WITH AFTERWARDS, AND
EVERYTHING IS PUT INTO THAT
PROCESS. AND THE REASON I
COMMITTED TO EVERYTHING THAT WAS
IN THE ANALYSIS IS BECAUSE THAT
ISN'T GOING TO BE AS EASY AS IT
SOUNDS IN MAKING SURE THERE'S NO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS
ADDRESSED. AND ON SOME OF THE
THINGS YOU SAID, THIS IS BOB
WIECKOWSKI, THE FORMER SENATOR
SAID TO ME ONCE Þ, A SENATOR
FROM SANTA CRUZ, YOU HAVE TO DO
A CANNABIS BILL EVERY YEAR AND,
AND THE THING IS, IS THAT THIS
IS THE FOURTH ONE, AND THEY HAVE
ALL ADDRESSED THESE THINGS THAT
ARE PARTS OF IT. BUT IN MANY
WAYS THEY'RE ON THE PERIPHERY.
WE DID NOT HAVE AN EDUCATION
LEAFLET THAT IS HANDED OUT TO A
FIRST TIME BUYER TO LET THEM
KNOW ABOUT WHAT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS ARE. DID THAT BILL LAST
YEAR IT WAS SIGNED, THERE WAS NO
STANDARDS FOR THE TESTING LABS
THAT WERE COMMON BETWEEN THE
LABS. I DID A BILL THAT
STANDARDIZED IT SO THAT IT COULD
BE TESTED AGAINST THE COMMON
FRAMEWORK AND AS WE TRIED TO
MAKE THE LEGAL WORK TO TRY TO
DISCOURAGE THE ILLEGAL, THERE
WAS THIS LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW
THAT IF A SHERIFF AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE WENT IN TO BUST A, AN
ILLEGAL GROW, IF THE WATER BOARD
WENT WITH THEM, THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO GIVE THEM 24 HOURS
NOTICE, WHICH WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO CLEAR OUT AND CLEAN
EVERYTHING UP. I DID A BILL THAT
THAT CHANGED THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE WATER BOARD
TO THE SAME FOR A SHERIFF OR
FISH AND WILDLIFE. AND IN THE
COURSE OF DOING ALL THIS, IT
BECAME REALLY CLEAR THAT THE
LICENSING PROJECT PROCESS WAS
INHIBITING PEOPLE AND DRIVING
THEM OUT. AND FRANKLY, IS
DRIVING OUT THE SMALLER PEOPLE
TO BENEFIT THE BIGGER PEOPLE.
AND THAT IS NOT WHAT SHOULD BE
HAPPENING HERE. SO BY
CONSOLIDATING IT, YOU ACTUALLY
ADDRESS EVERY ISSUE. BUT IN THAT
SEQUENCE THAT WAS NAMED, AND I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TELL
YOU HOW MANY DAYS IT'S GOING TO
TAKE. I CAN'T, BUT I CAN TELL
YOU IT WILL BE LESS AND THAT IS
THE GOAL OF THE BILL. WELL, I
THINK IF EVEN IF WE'RE 50% LESS,
THAT'S THAT'S A MOVEMENT, I'LL
MOVE THE BILL WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR NILO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. ONE OF THE ADAGES OF
LEGISLATION OR THE DELIBERATION
OF LEGISLATION IS THAT YOU CAN'T
MAKE A BAD BILL BETTER MERELY BY
CHANGING PIECES OF IT. I'M NOT
REFERRING TO YOUR BILL. I'M
REFERRING TO PROPOSITION 64, IT
IS UNFORTUNATELY, THE LAW AND IT
IS A TOTALLY DYSFUNCTIONAL LAW,
WHICH IS WHY WE CONTINUE TO SEE,
PROPOSALS LIKE YOURS TRYING TO
IMPROVE THINGS MORE OR LESS AT
THE EDGES. YOU'RE BEING SO DARN
AGREEABLE WITH REGARD TO THINGS
POINTED OUT IN THE ANALYSIS. I
JUST HAVE TO VOTE YES ON YOUR
BILL, WHICH I WILL KIND OF
RELUCTANTLY, THOUGH, BECAUSE, WE
CAN'T FIX PROPOSITION 64. I HAVE
CONCLUDED IT IS IMPOSSIBLE,
BILL, THAT PROPOSITION WAS
DEVELOPED, TO TRY TO PLEASE
EVERYBODY. AND A GREAT MAN ONCE
SAID, YOU CANNOT PLEASE ALL THE
PEOPLE ALL THE TIME. AND IN THIS
CASE, THAT ATTEMPT WAS MADE.
AND, IT IS IT IS BECOMING, I
THINK, A FAILED EXPERIMENT. AND,
AS IS POINTED OUT IN SENATOR
BRADFORD'S 1059, THE ITEM BEFORE
YOURS ON THE AGENDA DEALING AND
YET AGAIN WITH, REFORM WITH
REGARD TO CANNABIS, BOTH OF
THESE MODIFICATIONS, OF
PROPOSITION 64 REALLY BEG THE
QUESTION OF A COMPREHENSIVE
DISCUSSION OF THE FOUNDATIONAL
AND STRUCTURAL CHALLENGES OF
PROPOSITION 64 AS A WHOLE. AND
I'VE BECOME OF THE OPINION THE
ONLY WAY THIS CAN BE FIXED IS IF
THE LEGISLATURE ADDRESSES THAT
QUESTION AND PUTS A PROPOSITION
ON THE BALLOT, BECAUSE THAT'S
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN CHANGE 64 TO
FIX WHAT IS A FUNDAMENTALLY
DYSFUNCTIONAL, PIECE OF PUBLIC
POLICY. I WAS OPPOSED TO
PROPOSITION 64 TO BEGIN WITH,
AND I STILL DON'T PARTICULARLY
LIKE IT. AND I FIND MYSELF
VOTING FOR ALL OF THESE MEASURES
TO IMPROVE IT. AND IT FRUSTRATES
THE HECK OUT OF ME. BUT IT IS
THE LAW OF THE LAND. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO REPEAL IT, BUT IT NEEDS
TO BE FIXED IN A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE WAY THAN WE'RE
GOING ABOUT IT HERE. SO AS I
SAID, I'LL, I'LL, I'LL, I'LL
UNSATISFYINGLY SUPPORT, YOUR
PROPOSAL, BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
TAKE A MUCH DIFFERENT APPROACH
TO THIS HORRIBLY DYSFUNCTIONAL
SYSTEM. I THINK I'LL ADDRESS
THAT IN MY CLOSE IN CASE THERE'S
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. I HAVE A
COMMENT ON THE QUESTION ON THIS
ONE, AND IT'S IT IT LENDS ITSELF
NICELY TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE HERE, SENATOR
NILO. I, YOU KNOW, PERFECT OR
NOT PERFECT. PROP 64 IS THE LAW
OF THE LAND. AND SO I'M A BIT
RELUCTANT SOMETIMES, ESPECIALLY
IN THIS COMMITTEE, TO TAKE BILLS
THAT I THINK COULD POTENTIALLY
CHANGE WHAT VOTERS HAVE ALREADY
WEIGHED IN ON, UNLESS IT'S GOING
BACK TO THE BALLOT. SO IT'S MY
ONE WARNING SHOT OVER THE BOW
HERE ON YOUR BILL. AND I AM
SUPPORTING IT TODAY. BUT I
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
CHANGE WHAT THE VOTERS ASKED FOR
YET. BUT I'M ASKING YOU TO KEEP
THAT IN MIND AS YOU MOVE ALONG,
BECAUSE I'LL BE I'LL BE WATCHING
CAREFULLY FOR THAT PIECE. AND
THE OTHER PART OF THIS FOR ME IS
PROBABLY AUTHOR DRIVEN. I THINK
I WAS CONVINCED TO SUPPORT
BECAUSE OF WHO THE AUTHOR IS,
BECAUSE THIS BILL, IN ITS
CURRENT FORM, COULD BE DANGEROUS
IF SOMEBODY WASN'T OF THE MIND
TO WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE STAKEHOLDERS, ESPECIALLY THE
DEPARTMENT THOUGH. BUT I KNOW
YOU AND YOU ARE NOT GOING TO JAM
UP ANOTHER DEPARTMENT HEAD.
YOU'VE BEEN THERE YOURSELF. YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT FEELS LIKE. AND
YOU'RE GOING TO INCLUDE THEM. I
KNOW THAT TO BE TRUE. AND SO FOR
THAT REASON PRIMARILY, AND
BECAUSE I'M ASKING YOU TO MAKE
SURE YOU KEEP THOSE VOTERS IN
MIND AND GET THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED AS YOU GO THROUGH AS
MUCH AS YOU CAN. AND BEING THE
MEMBER THAT YOU ARE, I KNOW THAT
YOU WILL DO THAT. SO I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY. BUT I DO
THINK IT'S A LITTLE LOOSE
BECAUSE YOU'RE REALLY ASKING FOR
PERMISSION TO MOVE FORWARD AND
DO SOMETHING THAT DOES NEED TO
BE DONE. CLEARLY THERE'S ORDER
AND YOU REALLY LAID IT OUT
NICELY. I COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT VERY RECENTLY. IT'S
ONLY BEEN LIKE 18 MONTHS SINCE I
WAS SITTING ON A COUNCIL DAIS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO LINES UP WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE STATE ON
CANNABIS, AND THERE ARE SO MANY
QUESTIONS TO BE ANSWERED AROUND
CANNABIS IMPLEMENTATION AND IT
IS A STRUGGLE. SO IT WOULD BE
GOOD FOR THE GROUPS TO ALL BE
WORKING TOGETHER. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE DEPARTMENT IS IN A
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THAT
DISCUSSION, BUT I TRUST YOU WILL
DO THAT. OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO
SENATOR ROTH. YOU ARE YOU GOOD?
OKAY. SO SENATOR ARCHULETA, FOR
ONE FINAL THOUGHT, AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO HAND IT BACK TO
YOU. SENATOR LAIRD, SENATOR, YOU
BROUGHT UP ONE ONE VERY SMALL
POINT ABOUT THE ILLEGAL SIDE OF
THIS WHOLE INDUSTRY. AND I'M
HOPING AS A PIONEER YOU ARE. AND
STRAIGHTENING THIS THING OUT, AS
YOU'RE SAYING, THAT WE TURN THE
SCREWS UP A LITTLE BIT ON THE
ILLEGAL SIDE OF ALL THIS,
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT,
WORKING WITH WITH MUNICIPALITIES
, ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
STRENGTHEN THAT? BECAUSE THESE
ARE PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT, HARDWORKING BUSINESS
PEOPLE. AND WE'RE TRYING TO
SHARE THE WEALTH AND SHARE THE
OPPORTUNITY. Kò. BUT WE HAVE
THIS TERRIBLE SIDE, WHICH IS THE
ILLEGAL SIDE. SO I'M HOPING THAT
MAYBE YOU CAN JOIN WITH ME IN
THE FUTURE AND ALL THE OTHERS
THAT WANT TO SEE AN END TO THAT.
SO I'M JUST THROWING THAT OUT
THERE, AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL AS I SAID, I WILL MOVE IT.
EXCELLENT POINT. OKAY, SENATOR
LAIRD, YOU CAN GIVE US A, A
CLOSE AND THEN, YOU KNOW, WE'LL
HAVE TO WAIT FOR A QUORUM. WE
DON'T QUITE HAVE ONE YET. WE'RE
GETTING CLOSE. BUT BIG
COMMITTEE. SO WE NEED A COUPLE
MORE. I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE THE BACKGROUND
ISSUES CAME UP IN THE DISCUSSION
AND THE ONE THING I'VE THOUGHT
THAT IF YOU ACTUALLY MAKE THE
LEGAL PROCESS WORK AND YOU MAKE
IT ADVANTAGEOUS FOR PEOPLE TO
USE IT RATHER THAN THE ILLEGAL
ONE, RIGHT NOW, THERE'S NOT AN
ECONOMIC INCENTIVE FOR SOME
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE ILLEGAL
SIDE TO MOVE INTO THE LEGAL
SIDE. AND YES, I THINK THEY BOTH
NEED TO GO HAND IN HAND. BUT IF
WE CAN MAKE THE LEGAL SIDE WORK,
THAT'S PART OF THE INCENTIVE
THAT ADDRESSES THAT. AND I WAS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A
DIPLOMATIC WAY TO COMMENT ON THE
CHAIR'S COMMENT, BECAUSE ONE OF
THE STRANGEST THINGS ABOUT BEING
IN AN ADMINISTRATION IS WHEN YOU
MIGHT BE THE PERSON BEHIND A
BILL, BUT YOU ARE NOT AUTHORIZED
BY THE GOVERNOR TO TAKE A
POSITION OR LET ANYBODY KNOW OR
MAKE A PUBLIC STATEMENT. SO JUST
TRUST ME. I AM AND WILL WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE I
THINK THEY REALLY WANT TO MAKE
IT WORK. AND I APPRECIATE
SENATOR NEAL'S COMMENTS. AND I'M
VERY HAPPY BECAUSE, WHEN YOU
TOAD UP YES VOTES IT DOESN'T SAY
BEGRUDGING. IT JUST SAYS YES. SO
I AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT. BUT
I THINK THERE'S A REAL ELEMENT
OF TRUTH TO HIS FRUSTRATION. AND
I TRIED IN ADDITION TO THE BILLS
I MENTIONED, I TRIED THIS BILL
THE LAST TWO YEARS AND JUST GOT
STOPPED IN THE ASSEMBLY BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW, UNDER LICENSING, YOU
HAVE TO DO AN EIR ON THE SAME
PROJECT TWICE. THAT IS JUST
RIDICULOUS. AND THAT REALLY
WORKS AGAINST THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE THE SMALL LICENSEES AND
THOSE THAT ARE TRYING TO BREAK
INTO THE SYSTEM. AND IT MIGHT
MEAN PEOPLE OF COLOR AND CENTRAL
LOS ANGELES, IT MIGHT BE A SMALL
PEOPLE Ã GROWERS IN MORE RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE. AND SO I
THINK THIS IS A MORE LOGICAL WAY
TO GO AROUND IT. AND FRANKLY, IF
WE CAN'T MAKE THINGS LIKE THIS
WORK, IT MAKES THE CASE FOR YOUR
OVERALL POINT. AND SOMETIMES YOU
HAVE TO FAIL AT MAKING A SYSTEM
WORK FOR PEOPLE TO REALIZE THEY
WANT TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM. I
THINK THIS WILL MAKE IT
SUBSTANTIALLY BETTER IF WE CAN
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS, AND I
THINK IT IS REALLY WORTH AN
ATTEMPT AND THAT'S WHY I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION FOR WHEN WE GET THERE. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR
LAIRD. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
DURAZO, MY BIRTHDAY TWIN. WE'RE
TWINS, IN CASE YOU GUYS DIDN'T
KNOW, WE'RE THE SAME AGE. WE
HAVE THE SAME BIRTHDAY. THAT'S
ALL THAT MATTERS. YEAH WELCOME,
SENATOR DURAZO. NICE TO SEE YOU.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. FIRST,
I WANT TO THANK MADAM CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME AND MY STAFF ON
THIS BILL. AND I ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE WORK. AGAIN THESE ARE ALL
THE AMENDMENTS ALREADY OUTLINED
IN THE IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
, SB 1490 WILL STRENGTHEN THE
FAIR FOOD DELIVERY ACT BY
REQUIRING FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORMS TO DISCLOSE THE
CONSUMERS TO CONSUMERS. THE
ACTUAL COSTS INVOLVED IN ONLINE
FOOD ORDER AND DELIVERY. THE
BILL REQUIRES PLATFORMS TO
CREATE OPTIONAL MECHANISMS FOR
RESTAURANTS TO REMOVE THEMSELVES
FROM THE APPS AND DISCLOSE TO
CUSTOMERS ALL FEES CHARGED TO
THE RESTAURANT, INCLUDING ANY
ADDITIONAL DELIVERY FEE, SINCE
THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
RESTAURANTS EXPERIENCED A
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE SHIFT FROM
TRADITIONAL IN-PERSON DINING TO
ONLINE ORDERS, WHICH NOW AVERAGE
30 TO 40% OF RESTAURANT REVENUE.
RESTAURANTS PAY A DELIVERY
COMPANY A COMMISSION ON THEIR
SALES AND LISTING, MARKETING AND
PROCESSING FEES FOR LISTING THEM
ON THEIR PLATFORMS. HOWEVER,
THIRD PARTY FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORMS HAVE USED AND OFTEN
ABUSED THEIR LEVERAGE TO IMPOSE
HIGH AND HIDDEN FEES AND
ACTIVELY CUT RESTAURANTS OFF
FROM THEIR OWN CUSTOMERS. I LOOK
THESE WITH THESE CHANGES, ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
RESTAURANTS TO HAVE CLEAR
INFORMATION ABOUT FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORM PROCESSES. I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. I'M COMMITTED
TO FURTHER CLARIFYING WHERE
NEEDED TO PROTECT SMALL
RESTAURANTS FROM BEING UNFAIRLY
TREATED ON THE APPS AND TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL CHEF KEITH
CORBIN, EXECUTIVE CHEF AND
CO-OWNER OF ALTA ADAMS IN LOS
ANGELES, AND KAREEM WEBB,
RESTAURANT RESTAURATEUR AND
CO-FOUNDER OF PCF MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WELCOME THANKS FOR MAKING
YOUR WAY UP TO BE WITH US TODAY.
YOU EACH GET TWO MINUTES
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY, WELL,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
KAREEM WEBB. I'M A RESTAURATEUR
AND CO-FOUNDER OF PCF RESTAURANT
MANAGEMENT. I'VE DEDICATED MY
LIFE TO ADVOCATING AND ADVANCING
A MORE EQUITABLE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY, AND REMOVING BARRIERS,
ESPECIALLY FOR BLACK AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES SEEKING
ENTREPRENEURSHIP OPPORTUNITIES.
I GREW UP IN THE RESTAURANT
BUSINESS. AS A TEEN, I WORKED AT
MY PARENTS MCDONALD'S FRANCHISES
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY, TRAINING ON ALL
ASPECTS, ALL ASPECTS OF RUNNING
A BUSINESS. I THEN OPENED MY
FIRST FULL SERVICE RESTAURANT IN
SOUTH LA. AFTER THE LA UPRISING,
WHICH WAS MY FIRST BUFFALO WILD
WINGS LOCATION IN BALDWIN HILLS,
CALIFORNIA SINCE THEN, I'VE
OPENED ADDITIONAL UNITS IN
TORRANCE, CARSON, CHINATOWN, AND
KOREATOWN. OVER 25% OF MY
RESTAURANT SALES COME FROM
ONLINE ORDERS. WITH THIS DIGITAL
SHIFT, A POWER SHIFT HAS
OCCURRED WHERE THE BIG THREE
DELIVERY PLATFORMS HAVE CORNERED
THE ONLINE ORDER AND DELIVERY
MARKET. THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
PLATFORMS HAVE ALSO LEVERAGED
THIS POWER TO IMPOSE
INCREASINGLY HIGHER FEES ON
RESTAURANTS AND CONSUMERS, AND
ENGAGE IN BEHAVIORS THAT ARE
DRIVING SMALL BUSINESS
RESTAURANTS OUT OF BUSINESS. FOR
EXAMPLE, RESTAURANTS ARE
REPEATEDLY HIT WITH CHARGEBACKS
FOR ERRORS THAT OCCUR THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN. THE
LEGISLATION INCLUDES IMPORTANT
PROVISIONS PROVISIONS SUCH AS
PROHIBITING THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
PLATFORMS FROM LIMITING THE
VALUE OR NUMBER OF TRANSACTIONS
THAT WE CAN DISPUTE.
RESTAURANTS, PARTICULARLY SMALL
SHOPS SUCH AS MY FRIEND KEITH
CORBIN AND ALTA FIND THEMSELVES
OVERWHELMED BY COMPLEX APP
CONTRACTS THAT THAT MAKES THEM
FEEL PRESSURED TO SIGN, IF JUST
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE A
CHANCE TO MAKE IT IN SUCH A
DIFFICULT ENVIRONMENT. YOU CAN'T
BE IN BUSINESS OR IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO BE IN BUSINESS AND
COMPETE. IF YOU'RE NOT SIGNED UP
WITH THESE THIRD PARTY APPS.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD ALLOW
RESTAURANTS TO USE THIRD PARTY
CONSULTANTS TO WORK ON THEIR
BEHALF AND NEGOTIATE ON THEIR
BEHALF, SORT OF LIKE I HAVE
BUFFALO WILD WINGS, WHERE WE
HAVE OUR FRANCHISOR TO NEGOTIATE
MUCH BETTER TERMS THAN WOULD BE
THE CASE FOR ALTA AND MANY OTHER
SMALL AND INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS. SB 1490 WOULD HELP
TO BALANCE THE POWER IN THE
DYNAMIC IN THESE SITUATIONS AND
PROTECT OUR LOCAL RESTAURANTS
AND CONSUMERS FROM HARMFUL,
HARMFUL BUSINESS PRACTICES. AND
FOR THESE REASONS, I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. GREAT THANK YOU. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. OKAY CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, MY NAME IS KEITH
CORBIN. I'M THE EXECUTIVE CHEF
AND CO-OWNER OF ALTA ADAMS IN LA
. I GREW UP IN A JOINT HOUSING
PROJECTS IN WATTS, RAN WITH SOME
GUYS, EVENTUALLY WOUND UP GOING
TO PRISON. IT WAS IN PRISON WHEN
I FIRST STARTED COOKING AND
WORKING IN KITCHENS. I
EVENTUALLY LANDED A JOB WITH
LOCAL RESTAURANT GROUP RUN BY
CHEF ROY CHOI AND DANIEL
PATTERSON FROM THERE, I
PARTNERED WITH DANIEL ON ALTO
ADAMS TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA
SOUL FOOD RESTAURANT WHERE I
USED LOCAL, HEALTHIER
INGREDIENTS TO PUT MY OWN SPIN
ON THE FOOD I GREW UP COOKING
AND EATING WITH MY GRANDMOTHER
AS A CHEF, AS A CHEF AND
RESTAURATEUR OWNER. EXCUSE ME?
AS A CHEF AND RESTAURANT OWNER,
I SUPPORT SB 1490 AND THE
PROTECTIONS THAT PROVIDE OUR
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. AT ALTA
ADAMS, WE CANNOT AFFORD TO USE
THE DELIVERY PLATFORMS DUE TO
THE HIGH COST AND UNFAIR PRICING
IMPACTING CONSUMERS AND
CUSTOMERS. IT WAS NOT FEASIBLE
FOR US TO ABSORB THE HIGH FEES
THEY LITERALLY WAS ASKING FOR
30, THAT 30. IF I TACK THAT ON
TO MY PRICES, LIKE I WOULDN'T
SELL ON THAT PLATFORM ANYWAY.
AND THEN PEOPLE GET A
MISCONCEPTION ABOUT WHAT OUR
REAL PRICES IS IN THE
RESTAURANT, AND PROBABLY NOT
EVEN COME IN PERSON. AND SO I
CHOSE NOT TO GO WITH THE
PLATFORMS. MANY SMALL,
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY DO NOT HAVE THE LUXURY
OF QUITTING THE DELIVERY APPS.
NOW OVER 40% OF RESTAURANT SALES
COME FROM ONLINE ORDERS. THE
THIRD PARTY DELIVERY PLATFORMS
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF SMALL, FAMILY
OWNED RESTAURANTS THAT DON'T
HAVE THE TIME TO READ THE FINE
PRINT OR THE RESOURCES TO HAVE
LAWYERS NEGOTIATE FOR A FAIR
DEAL. IN MOST PARTS, THEY WON'T
TALK TO LAWYERS ANYWAY. THEY
ONLY WANT TO DEAL WITH THE
RESTAURANT OPERATOR. THEY GET
STUCK WITH THE COMMISSION AND
FEES THAT TAKE AWAY A LARGE
CHUNK OF THEIR RESTAURANT
REVENUE. SIMILARLY, THE
PLATFORMS TRICKED CONSUMERS WHO
HAVE NO IDEA THEY ARE PAYING
MORE FOR THEIR FOOD TO COVER
THESE EXORBITANT FEES.
EXORBITANT FEES, ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE CONSUMER HAS SIGNED UP TO
BECOME A MONTHLY MEMBER,
BELIEVING THEY ARE NOT BEING
CHARGED. ADDITIONAL DELIVERY
FEES. THEY OFTEN PLACE BLAME ON
RESTAURANTS FOR RISING PRICES
AND DON'T RETURN. SB 1490 WILL
HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
OUR FOR OUR LOCAL RESTAURANTS
AND CUSTOMERS. FOR THESE
REASONS, I ASK FOR SUPPORT OF
THIS CRITICAL MEASURE. THANK YOU
. DID A GREAT JOB CHEF. I'M GLAD
YOU CAME UP TODAY. THANKS FOR
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. NOW WOULD BE
THE TIME THAT ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE ROOM WHO IS ME TO TESTIMONY.
YOU CAN STAY. YOU GUYS CAN STAY
THERE FOR A MINUTE, ME TWO
TESTIMONY IN FAVOR COULD COME TO
THE MIC NAME, ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. ALL RIGHT.
IF THERE IS OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL OR TWEENERS ON THE BILL OR
LEAD OPPOSITION, LET ME KNOW.
ARE YOU LEAD, YES. GO AHEAD. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS. AUTHOR, ROBERT
MURRAY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB 1490
AT THIS TIME, I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR, AND I WANT TO THANK STAFF
SPONSOR, AUTHOR FOR WHAT HAS
BEEN I KNOW, A VERY DIFFICULT 72
HOURS WORKING ON AMENDS ON THIS.
AND WE APPRECIATE A LOT OF THOSE
AMENDS THAT HAVE ADDRESSED A LOT
OF OUR CONCERNS. I'M STILL
WAITING FOR FULL FEEDBACK FROM
MEMBERS AND GETTING THROUGH THAT
ANALYSIS MYSELF. SO WE CAN'T AT
THIS POINT, YOU KNOW, MOVE OFF
THAT. BUT I DO WANT TO UNDERLINE
HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATE THOSE, AS
PREVIOUSLY, OUR CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL WERE NEVER AROUND KIND
OF THE CORE GOALS, TRANSPARENCY,
YOU KNOW, SUPPORTING SMALL
RESTAURANTS. WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE
RESTAURANT MEMBERS AND SUPPORT
THAT. OUR CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
AROUND THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE AND
HOW WE WERE CONCERNED. SOME OF
THAT LANGUAGE WAS VAGUE, UNCLEAR
AND POTENTIALLY UNNECESSARY WITH
EXISTING PROTECTIONS IN LAW,
WHICH I THINK THE STAFF ANALYSIS
FLAGGED REALLY WELL THAT THE
LENGTHY EXISTING LAWS ON THIS
TOPIC, I WON'T GO THROUGH MORE
DETAIL, GIVEN THAT THE AMENDS
REALLY ARE THE CENTER OF
ATTENTION. SO WITH THAT, I'LL
PASS IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE, ANDREA DEVAULT, ON
BEHALF OF TECHNET, WE ALSO
REMAIN OPPOSED, ONLY BECAUSE WE
NEED TIME TO REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS. WE KNOW THAT IF ANY,
CONCERNS REMAIN, THE, THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SENATOR IN THIS COMMITTEE,
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE EXHAUSTIVE WORK OVER THE
WEEKEND, AND, AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK ON THE BILL. SO THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ME TOO. TESTIMONY AUSTIN
HAYWORTH, ON BEHALF OF UBER AND
UBER EATS, WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK ON THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE COMMITTEE. AND, ONCE WE SEE
THEM IN PRINT, WE MAYBE REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBER LEVINE,
ON BEHALF OF DOORDASH, WE ARE
NEUTRAL. THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK OF THE CHAIR OF STAFF AND
THE AUTHOR AT THIS POINT, AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WATCH AS IT
MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE HERE. GO AHEAD.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. OF COURSE, EQUALITY AND
FAIRNESS IS SO IMPORTANT TO ALL
OF US AND ESPECIALLY IN SOME OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT YOU AND I
BOTH REPRESENT, MY QUESTION IS
CLARITY. IF WE HAVE THE
RESTAURANT MAKING THE FOOD AND
IT'S GOT TO BE DELIVERED BECAUSE
THE CONSUMER WANTS IT DELIVERED,
ARE WE LOOKING AT A DISCLOSURE
OF THE DIFFERENCE? IF YOU PICK
IT UP VERSUS THE DELIVERY OR, OR
OR THE COMPANY THAT IS ACTUALLY
PICKING UP THE FOOD AND PICKING
UP THE TIPS AND SO ON, CAN YOU
CLARIFY THE STEPS FOR ME? WALK
ME THROUGH WHERE YOU FEEL THAT
IT'S OUT OF LINE. DO YOU DO YOU
FEEL LIKE THAT? WE CAN ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. I YEAH, I THINK,
I THINK I THINK GENERALLY, YEAH.
THE CONSUMER IS CONFUSED
NECESSARILY ABOUT THE FEES
GENERALLY WHAT KEITH IS TALKING
ABOUT AND WHAT WHAT HAPPENS HERE
IS THAT, AS A RESTAURATEUR,
YOU'RE, YOU'RE FORCED REALLY TO
KIND OF INFLATE YOUR COST AS IT
RELATES TO DELIVERY
SPECIFICALLY, BECAUSE WHAT YOU
PAY ON THE APPS, FOR INSTANCE, A
BUFFALO WILD WINGS, I HAVE A
NATIONAL, BRAND NEGOTIATING FOR
ME. WE PAY 20, RIGHT, FOR
KEITH'S RESTAURANT. HE WOULD
HAVE TO PAY 30, THAT'S THE DEAL
WITH THE DELIVERIES. AND SO YOU
HAVE TO PASS THAT COST ON TO THE
CONSUMER. SO IF YOU GO ON TO
BUFFALO WILD WINGS WEBSITE AND
YOU ORDER SIX WINGS, YOU'RE
GOING TO PAY 30% MORE, THAN YOU
WOULD PAY IF YOU CALLED THE
RESTAURANT AND ORDERED WINGS AND
CAME AND PICKED THEM UP ON TOP
OF THAT, YOU'RE GOING TO PAY THE
DELIVERY FEE AND THE TIP AND SO
WHAT KEITH IS TALKING ABOUT IS,
IS ASKING FOR REAL TRANSPARENCY
WITH RESPECT TO, YOU KNOW, WHAT
THOSE FEES ARE BECAUSE THEY'RE
CHARGING US IN ADDITION TO THE
FACT THAT THEY WANT TO CHARGE
YOU TO ADVERTISE ON THE APP AND
THEY OWN THE DATA. AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IN THE AMENDMENT, THE
DATA HAS COME OUT OF THIS, THE
BILL, BUT THEY OWN THE DATA. SO
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW, NECESSARILY
WHO OUR WHO OUR CUSTOMER IS. AND
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO THEN GO
SELL THAT CUSTOMER TO OUR
COMPETITOR. SO WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS, IS THEY'RE REALLY TÊ,
KIND OF MONOPOLIZING THE
MARKETPLACE IN A WAY THAT MAKES
IT VERY DIFFICULT AND ALREADY
VERY DIFFICULT POST COVID
ENVIRONMENT FOR RESTAURATEURS,
TO TAKE THE RISK OF BEING
ENTREPRENEURS AND TO HIRING
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND TO,
YOU KNOW, BEING THE STEWARDS OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND WHAT'S IN THE
INTEREST OF OUR COMMUNITY, WHICH
IS WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR US
TO HAVE A LOCAL FRANCHISEES AND
LOCAL RESTAURANT OWNERS, BECAUSE
IN A CAPITALISTIC DEMOCRACY, YOU
KNOW, THE PEOPLE THAT TAKE THE
RISK HAVE TO BE REWARDED. AND,
AND, AND THESE APPS ARE STANDING
IN THE WAY FROM US HAVING A
DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
CONSUMER AND STANDING IN THE WAY
OF THE CONSUMER REALLY KNOWING
HOW MUCH THEY'RE PAYING TO WHO.
OKAY MADAM CHAIR, MAY I
CONTINUE? YOU MENTIONED THE WORD
INFLATION. SO OBVIOUSLY IT'S
BEEN INFLATED AT THE OTHER END.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT A PLATFORM
THAT DISCLOSES THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO THAT YOU CAN
COME AND PICK IT UP VERSUS WHAT
YOU'RE PAYING HERE. WELL AND TO
NEGOTIATE ON THE BEHALF OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE A BUFFALO
WILD WINGS CORPORATE AND A BIG
APPARATUS TO NEGOTIATE WITH, YOU
KNOW, SO YOU'RE NOT ASKING TO
ELIMINATE THEM. YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR A BETTER A POLICY TO COME TO
AN AGREEMENT AND NEGOTIATE.
YEAH. WE'RE TO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO NEGOTIATE ON, ON, ON, ON ON
THE BEHALF OF THE OPERATOR, I
CAN CHOOSE, YOU KNOW WHAT
ATTORNEY THAT I WANT IF I GO TO
HIRE AN ATTORNEY OR WHAT REPAIR
PERSON THAT I WANT, IF I NEED TO
HAVE MY HVAC REPAIRED OR WHAT
SUPPLIER, OR PRODUCE SUPPLIER OR
WHATEVER IT IS THAT, THAT I WANT
TO USE TO SUPPLY MY BUSINESS,
WE'RE ASKING TO BE ABLE TO ALSO
HAVE AN INTERMEDIARY WITH THESE,
THIRD PARTY APPS. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, CAN I GO ON TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES HERE? ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU, I
JUST REMEMBER VOTING ON THE
GONZALEZ BILL AND THEN THE LEE
BILL. AND I WAS LOOKING THROUGH
THE ANALYSIS. MAYBE THE LEAD
BILL WAS VETOED. I WAS TRYING TO
. I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED WITH ALL THAT.
SHE'S ASKING IF THE SENATOR
COULD YOU WALK US THROUGH WHAT
WERE SOME OF THE PAST ACTIONS?
DID THEY NOT HAVE THE EFFECT
THAT, WAS HOPED OR ANY ANY
INSIGHT INTO THAT, YEAH. LET ME
JUST FIND THERE, SO WHAT SB 1490
IS DOING IS PROVIDING, A
MECHANISM FOR RESTAURANTS THAT
HAVE RIGHTS ALREADY UNDER THE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ, FOR
THE FOOD FACILITY TO DIRECT THAT
THE FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORM
DISCLOSED TO CUSTOMERS THE
DELIVERY FEE CHARGED TO THE FOOD
FACILITY AND EACH FEE COMMISSION
OR COST CHARGED TO THE FOOD
FACILITY. SO, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU,
YOU KNOW, IT MIGHT SAY ZERO
DELIVERY FEES WHEN IN FACT
RESTAURANTS ARE BEING CHARGED
FEES FOR MEAL DELIVERY. RIGHT I
MEAN, WHAT IT SAYS. AND IN FACT,
THE RESTAURANTS ARE HAVING TO
PICK UP THAT THAT DELIVERY FEE,
SO IT'S, IT'S, CLARIFYING AND
IT'S STRENGTHENING. THE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ. BILL.
OKAY. SO YOUR VIEW IS BUILDING
ON THAT. YES YES. OKAY. AND THEN
THE CONVERSATIONS SO IT SOUNDS
LIKE THE CONVERSATION. I'M SORRY
I MISSED THE BEGINNING, THE
PRESENTATION, BUT THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE GONE WELL
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND. YES,
YES, YES, I UNDERSTAND I TOOK
HERE THAT DOORDASH WENT NEUTRAL.
DID I GET THAT RIGHT? DOORDASH
WENT NEUTRAL AS A RESULT OF
AMENDMENTS, AND THE OTHERS ARE
LOOKING AT THE AMENDMENTS TO
DECIDE WHAT POSITION THEY TAKE.
SEVERAL OF THEM MOVED TO
NEUTRAL, AND THE OTHERS ARE ALL
JUST JUST NEED A LITTLE MORE
TIME TO REVIEW IT. HER AND HER
STAFF HAVE DONE AN INCREDIBLE
JOB WITH THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OKAY. WOULD YOU
LIKE. I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT, SENATOR DURAZZO, SHE SHE
WALKS THE WALK IN THIS BUILDING
AND HER AND HER STAFF TREAT
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH TREMENDOUS
RESPECT. AND BECAUSE OF THAT,
THEY REALLY ENJOY WORKING WITH
YOU AND YOUR TEAM. AND I ALSO
THINK BECAUSE OF THAT, YOUR
BILLS COME OUT REALLY WELL
VETTED. AND SO I APPRECIATE YOU
SO MUCH. YOU'RE VERY HARD
WORKING, SENATOR. THIS IS A GOOD
BILL. I'M PROUD TO OFFER MY
SUPPORT TO IT TODAY. THANK YOU.
WE MIGHT HAVE A QUORUM IF. CAN
YOU ALL ASK, SENATOR NGUYEN TO
COME BACK IN SO WE COULD
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, AND WE'LL
ASK YOU TO CLOSE WHILE SHE COMES
IN. THEN I'LL TAKE THE ROLL
CALL, AND THEN WE'LL BE ABLE TO
TAKE A VOTE ON YOUR BILL. GREAT.
WELL, I'M GLAD THAT WE HAVE
WITNESSES, HERE. WHO CAN WHO
ACTUALLY DO THE WORK EVERY DAY.
AND WHO UNDERSTAND THE INDUSTRY
AND WHAT'S NEEDED BOTH FOR
BUSINESS AND FOR CONSUMERS AND
THANK YOU ALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. AND YOUR
STAFF. AND I WOULD APPRECIATE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR OSO. WELL DONE. OKAY.
CAN WE PLEASE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
HERE AND THEN WE'LL TAKE UP
SENATOR DROSSOS BILL ASHBY HERE.
ASHBY HERE. WHEN? WHEN HERE.
ALVARADO ARCHULETA HERE.
ARCHULETA HERE. BECKER. BECKER
HERE. DODD. EGGMAN. GLASER.
MENGIBAR. NILO NILO. HERE. ROTH.
ROTH. HERE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. HERE. WILK.
GREAT. WE HAVE A MOTION, I
BELIEVE, FROM SENATOR ARCHULETA
ON THIS BILL ON SENATOR DROSSOS,
SB 1490. LET'S CALL THE ROLL. A
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO SEND IT TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
ASHBY. AYE ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN
ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE. DODD EGGMAN. GLASER.
MENGIBAR. NILO WE'RE VOTING ON
THE DURAZZO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK OKAY, THAT'S
FIVE AND ZERO. SO WE'LL PUT IT
ON CALL FOR THE REST OF THE
MEMBERS TO GET HERE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR DURAZZO. ALL
RIGHT. YEAH, WE CAN TAKE A LET'S
GO AHEAD. AND WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION ON SENATOR LAIRD'S 1064.
I BELIEVE THAT CAME FROM SENATOR
ARCHULETA. CAN WE GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL ON THAT ONE? YES.
SB 1064, MOTION TO DO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. WHEN
ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER BECKER.
AYE. DODD. EGGMAN. LASER
MENGIBAR. NILO. NILO AYE. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. WILK.
THAT'S 6 TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
ON CALL. ALSO FOR THE REST OF
THE MEMBERS TO GET HERE. THOSE
ARE THE ONLY TWO BILLS THAT WE
HAVE HEARD SO FAR. I DID SEE
SENATOR BRADFORD IN THE BACK OF
THE ROOM. SENATOR BRADFORD, ARE
YOU PREPARED? READY TO GO? YOU
ARE ALWAYS PREPARED. ALWAYS STAY
READY. STAY READY, STAY READY.
GET READY. ALL RIGHT. WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY, SENATOR BRADFORD.
WELL, GOOD MORNING, SENATOR
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT 1059, WHICH WILL ASSIST
LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY BY,
ALLEVIATING SOME OF THE
TREMENDOUS TAX BURDENS THAT ARE
PLACED ON THIS INDUSTRY. HERE IS
AN INDUSTRY THAT'S JUST SEVEN
YEARS IN EXISTENCE, AND IT'S
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE. IT'S
STRUGGLING BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
TAXES, THE EXCESSIVE REGULATORY
HURDLES AND VARIOUS CHALLENGES
THAT THE CANNABIS BUSINESS FACES
THAT HAVE DONE LITTLE TO HELP
THE LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET
SUCCEED THE WAY THE VOTERS HAD
INTENDED. WITH PROP 64, EIGHT
YEARS AGO, THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS. SPECIFICALLY, IT
PROHIBITS A LOCAL JURISDICTION
FROM INCLUDING THE STATE'S
EXCESS TAX AND SALES TAX FROM
THEIR DEFINITION OF GROSS
RECEIPTS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
LOCAL CANNABIS TAXES. THIS WOULD
ELIMINATE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT'S
COLLECTION OF A TAX ON A TAX. NO
OTHER INDUSTRY HAS A TAX ON A
TAX. TAXING THE TAX AND
ULTIMATELY INCREASING PRICES,
PURCHASE PRICES, I SHOULD SAY,
PUSHES CONSUMERS AWAY FROM THE
LEGAL RETAILERS AND ONLY WORSENS
THE CONTINUED STRUGGLE OF THE,
CANNABIS RETAILERS, CURRENTLY,
IT'S ALMOST A 47% MARKUP VERSUS
LEGAL VERSUS ILLEGAL. SECOND
THREE, THE BILL ELIMINATES THE
AUTHORITY OF THE CDTFA VÀ TO
IMPOSE A 50% PENALTY ON CANNABIS
LICENSEES. DELINQUENT TAXES.
THIS 50% PENALTY IS ON TOP OF
OTHER PENALTIES THAT THE
LICENSEES ALREADY MUST PAY,
INCLUDING A 10% FEE FOR FAILING
TO FILE A RETURN OR FILING LATE,
A 25% PENALTY FOR FRAUD OR
INTENT TO EVADE REGULATIONS, AND
A $500 PENALTY FOR FAILING TO
FURNISH A RETURN OR A REPORT.
THIS 50% PENALTY IS PUNITIVE. IT
CREATES A SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIP
FOR LICENSEES WHO ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH THE VARIOUS
CHALLENGES, CHANGES, I SHOULD
SAY, TO THE CANNABIS LAWS AND
HAS NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
INCREASING COMPLIANCE. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE CHANGES TO
PROP 64 BEFORE. AS RECENTLY AS
2022, WHEN WE STOPPED THE
COLLECTION OF THE CULTIVATION
TAX. ALTHOUGH THE VOTERS
APPROVED THIS PENALTY AND PROP
64, IT IS CLEAR TO ME AND ALL
THE LEGAL OPERATORS IN THIS
INDUSTRY THAT THIS PENALTY IS
NOT HELPING THE CANNABIS MARKET
SUCCEED. IT'S ONLY AIDING IN THE
OVERLY EXCESSIVE PENALTIES TO
THIS BUSINESS THAT ARE ALREADY
OVERTAXED AND OVERBURDENED. ALL
THAT BEING SAID, I UNDERSTAND
THE COMMITTEE'S CONCERNS AND I
AM WILL BE WILLING TO ACCEPT
YOUR AMENDMENTS, AND I THANK YOU
, FOR YOUR. I VOTE TODAY AND WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES HERE WILLING
TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BRADFORD.
WITNESSES. YOU'LL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. I'M GOING TO STEP OUT
FOR JUST A MOMENT. SO VICE CHAIR
NGUYEN IS GOING TO TAKE OVER.
I'LL BE RIGHT BACK. PLEASE GO
FORWARD. SURE. PLEASE LET ME
APOLOGIZE FOR THE AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION I FEEL I NEED TO
GIVE EVERY COMMITTEE HEARING SO
THAT WE ARE ALL IN THE SAME
CONTEXT OF WHAT THE PROBLEMS
ARE, WHAT THE ENVIRONMENT LOOKS
LIKE, WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS IF
WE CONTINUE AT THIS TRAJECTORY.
AB 195 CHANGED EVERYTHING WHEN
IT CAME TO THE PURPOSE AND
INTENT OF THE VOTERS OF PROP 64,
WE ELIMINATED THE CULTIVATION
TAX COLLECTION, MOVED THE
COLLECTION OF EXCISE TAX AWAY
FROM THE DISTRIBUTOR LICENSE,
MOVED THE CALCULATION OF EXCISE
TAX FROM THE WHOLESALE PRICE
LEVEL TO A GROSS RECEIPTS LEVEL.
WHEN WE CHANGE THAT COLLECTION,
THE EXCISE TAX WAS CHARGED AND
CALCULATED TO INCLUDING TAXING
OTHER TAXES. ALL TAXES ARE DUE
AND REMITTED BY THE RETAILER.
NOW UNDER THIS NEW LAW, THIS
UNDUE HARDSHIP AND STRESS IS
EXACERBATED BY THE THREAT AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A 50%
PENALTY ON ANY LATER UNDERPAID
TAXES. AB 195 WAS UNANIMOUSLY
VOTED IN BY THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY CDTFA JUST RECENTLY
STATED THAT 15% OF CANNABIS
OPERATORS WERE IN DEFAULT OF
SALES AND TAX OBLIGATIONS. SALES
AND USE TAX OBLIGATIONS, WITH
ANOTHER 15% THAT WERE LATE OR AN
EXISTING PAYMENT. PROGRAMS.
CDTFA JUST ESTIMATED THAT OVER
15% ARE IN DEFAULT OF EXCISE TAX
OBLIGATIONS, WITH ANOTHER 15%
THAT ARE LATE OR IN PAYMENT
PROGRAMS. THAT IS $300 MILLION
IN DEFAULT BACK TAXES AND 300
MILLION IN LATE TAXES OR IN
PAYMENT PROGRAMS. IF WE ADD A
50% PENALTY TO $600 MILLION IN
BACK TAXES, WE NOW HAVE CLOSE TO
$1 BILLION OF DEBT AND TAXES
THAT ARE OWED, INCLUDING
PENALTIES AND FEES. THE DCC JUST
ESTIMATED THAT 40% OF LICENSEES
WILL GO 15 DAYS BEYOND THEIR
CONTRACT, WITH ACCOUNTS
RECEIVABLE FOR VENDOR PAYMENTS,
AND ANOTHER 40% OF THAT 40% WILL
BE OVER A YEAR LATE. I'M SAYING
ALL THIS SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND
THE LEVEL OF DEBT THAT THIS
INDUSTRY IS CURRENTLY IN, AND
EXACERBATING THAT WITH A 50%
PENALTY IS DOING NOTHING TO
SUPPORT THE INDUSTRY'S GROWTH
AND TO SUPPORT THE FACT THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ELIMINATE THE
ILLEGAL MARKET, WHAT DOES A
MEDIUM OR LARGE SIZE DO? YOU CAN
WRAP IT UP, PLEASE? SURE. A
MEDIUM AND LARGE SIZE DISPENSARY
HAS $10 MILLION IN REVENUE. THAT
IS A $1.5 MILLION IN EXCISE TAX,
$1 MILLION IN SALES TAX, AND $1
MILLION IN LOCAL TAXES. ANY OF
THOSE THAT ARE UNDERPAID OR NOT
PAID, YOU LOSE YOUR LICENSE OR
YOU HAVE $750,000 IN PENALTIES
AND FEES. WE NEED TO REIN THIS
IN. AND I THINK PASSING THIS
BILL AT LEAST PUT US IN A GOOD
DIRECTION. I APOLOGIZE, I
THOUGHT THAT WAS TWO MINUTES.
THAT'S PAST TWO MINUTES,
ACTUALLY, I DON'T THINK YOU
MENTIONED YOUR NAME. DID YOU
MENTION YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION? JARED. KYLA WITH
THE UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. STICK WITH TWO
MINUTES, PLEASE. YES, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AMY JENKINS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION, I
WILL BE BRIEF, I THINK WHAT MR.
KALO SAID, I'LL JUST EMPHASIZE,
WE ARE IN A STATE OF CRISIS,
RECENT DATA FROM CDTFA DOES
PAINT A FAIRLY BLEAK PICTURE,
OUR TAX BALANCE, AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT, IS 287 MILLION
AND GROWING. WE ARE ESTIMATING A
TOTAL 600 MILLION, WHICH I THINK
MR. KALO MENTIONED, WE'RE
INCREASINGLY LISTED ON CDTFA A'S
LIST OF TOP 500 SALES AND USE
TAX DELINQUENCIES. I THINK THE
PRIMARY GOAL I'LL JUST EMPHASIZE
OF PROPOSITION 64, WHICH WAS
REFERENCED FIRST AND IN NO LESS
THAN FIVE ADDITIONAL TIMES.
AGAIN VOTER INTENT AND PURPOSE
WAS TO GET RID OF THE ILLICIT
MARKET, MORE SPECIFICALLY TO
ESTABLISH TAX MEASURES THAT
UNDERMINE ILLICIT SALES, DETER
ILLEGAL PRODUCTION, AND
DISTRIBUTION, AND PREVENT THE
UNLAWFUL DIVERSION OF CANNABIS,
AND TO GENERATE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND NEW
STATE REVENUE ANNUALLY. IT OUGHT
TO BE SELF-EVIDENT, BUT THAT IS
NOT HAPPENING. AND THAT IS WHY
THIS BILL IS HERE TODAY BEFORE
YOU, FOR THESE REASONS, Kò
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTS THIS
BILL AS A PROUD CO-SPONSOR. AND
THANKS THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME, ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
ALICIA PRIEGO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AND
ALSO KIVA CONFECTIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. TALIA D'AMATO, ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA NORML AND
SUPPORT. KRISTEN HEIDELBACH ON
BEHALF OF UFCW WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SAM
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF GOOD
FARMERS, GREAT NEIGHBORS BASED
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY, AND
ALSO WANT TO APPLAUD THE CAREER
AND LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR
BRADFORD ON TAX FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY AND STRONG SUPPORT
MEMBERS. GEORGE MILLER, ON
BEHALF OF WEEDMAPS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. RYAN, ELAINE, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME,
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
STATE IN OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE
AT THIS TIME, WE'LL MOVE TO,
MEMBERS, COLLEAGUES, BAKER.
SURE. I'LL JUST SAY THAT
WHENEVER THIS TOPIC COMES UP, I
KNOW IT NEEDS TO BE FIXED. AND
I'M GLAD THERE ARE PEOPLE
WORKING ON FIXING IT. AND, JUST
APPRECIATE IT. I'LL MOVE THE
BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE. TIME.
THANK YOU, SENATOR HILO. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AVOIDING
CHARGING A TAX ON A TAX IS,
SENSIBLE AND VERY GOOD TAX
POLICY, WHICH WE DON'T PRACTICE
ALL THE TIME, BY THE WAY, LIKE
ON GASOLINE, BUT I DIGRESS,
UNDER THE HEADING OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF REDUNDANCY.
DEPARTMENT YOU WEREN'T HERE WHEN
WE HEARD SENATOR LAIRD'S BILL,
BUT MY COMMENT IS THE SAME. I
WILL SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION,
BUT WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO FIX AN
UNFIXABLE THING PROPOSITION 64,
IT HAS BEEN MENTIONED THAT IT'S
IN CRISIS SITUATION, AND I DON'T
THINK WE CAN CHANGE THAT, UNDER
THE DETAILS OF PROP 64, AS IS
STATED IN THIS, ANALYSIS TO AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF REDUNDANCY
DEPARTMENT. BUT I SAID THIS
BEFORE, IT BEGS THE QUESTION OF
A COMPREHENSIVE DISCUSSION OF
THE FOUNDATIONAL AND STRUCTURAL
CHALLENGES OF PROPOSITION 64 AS
A WHOLE. AND, ANY TINKERING
AROUND THE EDGES OF THE CURRENT
SYSTEM, WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE A
DYSFUNCTIONAL CURRENT SYSTEM.
AND I THINK THE ONLY REAL, CURE
TO THAT IS A FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE
TO 64, WHICH WE WOULD HAVE TO
PUT ON THE BALLOT. AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE, I DID NOT
SUPPORT PROPOSITION 64 AND I
WOULDN'T SUPPORT IT TODAY IF IT
WAS UP FOR THE FIRST TIME. BUT
IT IS THE LAW OF THE LAND, AND
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN CHANGE IT TO
TRY TO MAKE IT FUNCTIONAL IS IF
THE LEGISLATURE PUTS A
PROPOSITION ON THE BALLOT TO DO
THAT, ALL OF THESE CHANGES
REALLY BEG THAT FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. AND, YOU KNOW, I, I
BELIEVE WHEN VOTERS SPEAK,
VOTERS SPEAK. AND IT'S OUR JOB
TO MAKE, PROP 64 WORK. AND THIS
IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE WORK THAT
CONTINUES, MY QUESTION IS, YOU
KNOW, I UNDERSTAND THE DEBT. MY
QUESTION IS HOW HOW DO YOU ALL,
DO YOU HAVE CHALLENGES IN TRYING
TO CALCULATE WHAT THE TAX BURDEN
IS? I'M CURIOUS HOW YOU DO THAT.
IN TERMS OF, YOU KNOW, HOW DO
HOW DO YOU CALCULATE HOW MUCH IS
OWED AND IS THAT WHAT LEVEL OF
BURDEN IS IT TO EVEN COME UP
WITH THAT, THAT NUMBER? I'M
CURIOUS HOW YOU HOW THAT HAPPENS
, AS AN OPERATOR AND SOMEONE WHO
HAS BEEN A PART OF THIS
REGULATORY PROCESS FOR THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS, WHEN THE LAW
CHANGED UNDER AB 195, WE ASKED
FOR CLARITY NOT ONLY FROM OUR
CITY, BUT FROM OUR STATE. AND
NOVEMBER. I THINK IT WAS THE
24TH OF THE YEAR BEFORE. IT'S
GOING TO CHANGE IN JANUARY. WE
WE'RE GIVING A LITTLE BIT OF
GUIDANCE, BUT THAT GUIDANCE WAS
ACTUALLY IN CONFLICT WITH LOCAL
LAW. SO THEN WE HAD CDTFA
COMMUNICATE, ESPECIALLY TO THE
LA OFFICE OF FINANCE, TO SAY WHO
IS GOING TO BE THE LAST TAX YOU
BOTH HAVE CLAIMED YOU'RE THE
LAST TAX AND YOU'RE TAXING OTHER
TAXES. HOW DO WE DO THIS? IT IS
ONLY RECENTLY, IN THE LAST MONTH
THAT THE OFFICE OF FINANCE IN
LOS ANGELES FINALLY GAVE OUT.
NOW WE'RE TALKING LIKE ALMOST A
YEAR INTO THIS, THAT THEY
FINALLY GAVE GUIDANCE ON WHAT
THEY WOULD LIKE YOU TO DO TO
ESTIMATE YOUR TAXES. THE STATE
GAVE GUIDANCE, I THINK IT WAS IN
APRIL OF, OF THIS YEAR TO ALSO
GIVE GUIDANCE, WHICH IS 5 TO 11
MONTHS PAST WHEN WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO START CALCULATING
IT. IT IS NOT ONLY CONFUSING FOR
EVEN THE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES,
BUT VERY CONFUSING FOR THE
OPERATORS. AND ANYTHING WE DO
WRONG IS A PENALTY. IT'S A FEE
OR IT'S A THREAT OF YOUR LICENSE
BEING REMOVED. ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ADD STRESS NOT ONLY TO
THE EMPLOYEES, BUT ALSO TO THE
BUSINESS OWNERS AND THE
COMMUNITY IN GENERAL. LIKE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO. AND YOU
KNOW, AND EVEN WHAT WE GOT IS
GUIDANCE FROM THE OFFICE OF
FINANCE SAID, WELL, INSTEAD OF
CHARGING 10% GROSS RECEIPTS TAX
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO TAX THE
EXCISE TAX CHARGED 12.99% TO
MAKE SURE YOU COVER YOUR. BUT
FOR THE OFFICE OF FINANCE, WELL,
GUESS WHAT THEY SAID TO DO WITH
EXCISE TAX AT THE STATE LEVEL.
INSTEAD OF CHARGING 15% CHARGE
16.5% TO THE CUSTOMER SO THAT
YOU ARE COVERING YOUR BUTT FOR
THE STATE, THUS INCREASING THE
TAXES ON THE TAXES WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE HERE. AND THIS IS THE
SECOND TIME WE'VE RUN THIS BILL,
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ONLY CONFUSING,
IT'S PUNITIVE, AND IT DOESN'T
EVEN MAKE SENSE AT THIS POINT
THAT WE'RE TAXING THINGS THAT
AREN'T EVEN SERVICES OR GOODS.
WELL, THANK YOU FOR THAT
IN-DEPTH OVERVIEW, AND THE
COMPLEXITY REALLY REINFORCES THE
NEED FOR, FOR. THIS BILL AND FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN TO SENATOR
BRADFORD. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. YES THANK YOU,
SENATOR BRADFORD, BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
PROBLEM IN THE INDUSTRY. AND I
DON'T THINK WHEN WE WHEN WE
PASSED PROP 64 WAS TO BE
PUNITIVE TO THE BUSINESS OWNER
TO BE PUNITIVE FOR THOSE THAT
WANTED TO EXPAND THEIR HORIZONS
AND BE PART OF THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY, TO BE PUNITIVE FOR
THOSE THAT ARE TRYING TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES. AND I THINK
THAT NOW WE ANALYZE WHAT WE'VE
DONE, WE'VE GOT TO CLARIFY IT
AND LEVEL THE SHIP. AND TO A
DEGREE, WHEN WE HEAR ABOUT TAX
UPON TAX, AND AGAIN, THAT'S A
PROBLEM. THEN, OF COURSE, WHERE
YOU GET DEEPER AND DEEPER AND
DEEPER IN DEBT, AND EVENTUALLY
YOUR DOORS CLOSE BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER, THOSE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT IN THE
INNER CITIES, THOSE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO BE PART OF THE
EQUALITY IN THIS. SO I THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO, GO ALONG WITH
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'LL
STRAIGHTEN THE SHIP OUT
SOMEWHAT, IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
PERFECT. AND I'M SURE THERE'S
AMENDMENTS TO FOLLOW. AND I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO PROBABLY TALK
ABOUT THE, THE REPEALING THE
CURRENT PENALTY, BUT MAKING SOME
ADJUSTMENTS. AND I'M SURE YOU'RE
GOING TO BE WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE ON THAT. SO I THINK WE
HAVE A MOVEMENT ON THE BILL, AND
I BELIEVE WE DO. I THINK WE HAVE
A SUPPORTING THE BILL MOTION
FROM SENATOR BECKER. ALL RIGHT.
DID YOU WANT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE, SENATOR? YES. I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS ISSUE. AND AS YOU HEARD
FROM THE WITNESSES, THIS IS A
VERY, ONEROUS SITUATION THAT WE
FIND OURSELVES IN BECAUSE WE
WERE SO DESPERATE ON PASSING
PROP 64 THAT WE TOOK A
PROPOSITION THAT WAS REALLY
POORLY WRITTEN, THAT WAS LADEN
WITH A WHOLE LOT OF PITFALLS
THAT REALLY DIDN'T HELP STAND UP
TO INDUSTRY, BUT WE WERE JUST SO
DESPERATE FOR PASSING SOMETHING
TO LEGALIZE. WHAT IS A PLANT?
AND WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO IS
GET PAST THE STIGMA OF CALLING
WHAT WAS GOD MADE A DRUG VERSUS
WHAT IS MAN MADE, WHICH IS TRULY
A DRUG. THIS IS A PLANT THAT WAS
HERE BEFORE ALL OF US AND SOME
OF THE OWNERS PENALTIES ON THIS
IS BECAUSE OF THE STIGMAS THAT
WE STILL HAVE AS IT RELATES TO
CANNABIS. THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE, AND I
WOULD JUST SAY ONE OF THE
PREVIOUS WITNESSES ON A PREVIOUS
ISSUE WAS IN THIS INDUSTRY TWO
YEARS AGO. THEY'RE NO LONGER IN
THIS INDUSTRY BECAUSE OF THESE
EXORBITANT TAX. THIS INDUSTRY
HAS NOT GROWN LEGALLY. IT'S ONLY
GROWN ILLEGALLY. AND FOR THAT
REASON, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THANKS FOR
WORKING SO WELL WITH COMMITTEE
TO SENATOR BRADFORD. REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU. LET'S CALL THE
ROLL HERE. MOTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED AS SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ASHBY I ASHBY I
NGUYEN ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA
I ARCHULETA I BECKER. BECKER I
DODD. EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GLASER.
MENGIBAR NILO I NILO I ROTH ROTH
I SMALL WITH CUEVAS WILK.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK. SEVEN
SEVEN 7 TO 0. BUT WE'LL STILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. IT'S OUT WITH
SEVEN. THANK YOU. BUT WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS. APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. OKAY SEEING NO
NON-COMMITTEE AUTHORS. SENATOR
ROTH, YOU WANT TO PRESENT, IF
YOU WANT ME TO. SURE YOU HAVE
YOUR WITNESSES AND EVERYTHING
THAT YOU NEED. WITNESSES ALL
RIGHT. WELL HE DOESN'T NEED
WITNESSES. THE GENERAL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. LET'S GO. JUST
OPPONENTS. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
ROTH, WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THIS
BILL REQUIRES ALL NURSING
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO REPORT THEIR
CLINICAL PLACEMENT NEEDS TO THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING.
LIKEWISE, THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
LICENSED DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND INFORMATION,
HEALTH FACILITIES AND CLINICS TO
REPORT ON CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS FOR NURSING STUDENTS. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO AUTHORIZE THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING AT
ITS OPTION, UPON REQUEST, BY A
NURSING SCHOOL OR PROGRAM, TO
ASSIST IN FINDING CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS TO MEET THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT NEEDS OF THAT
PARTICULAR SCHOOL OR PROGRAM.
REMEMBER, THIS IS PERMISSIVE ON
THE PART OF THE BERN NOT
REQUIRED, AND IF THE BOARD
RECEIVES SUCH REQUESTS FROM
SCHOOLS AND DECIDES TO
PARTICIPATE, THE BOARD IS
REQUIRED TO PRIORITIZE THE
REQUEST FROM PUBLIC NURSING
PROGRAMS WITH THE BOARD'S
ASSISTANCE AS YOU MAY KNOW, ONE
OF THE MAJOR BOTTLENECKS TO
GROWING CAPACITY IN OUR NURSING
PROGRAMS IS THE CHALLENGE OF
LOCATING AND SECURING THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE CLINICAL
TRAINING REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A
NURSING DEGREE. THE 2020 STATE
AUDITOR REPORT ON THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING FOUND THAT
DUE TO A LACK OF RELIABLE DATA,
THE BOARD LACKED CRITICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LOCATION
AND AVAILABILITY OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS IN ORDER TO MAKE
ENROLLMENT DECISIONS. THIS BILL
DOES JUST THAT BY COLLECTING
DATA ON NURSING PROGRAMS,
CLINICAL PLACEMENT NEEDS, AND
COLLECTING DATA FROM HEALTH
FACILITIES AND CLINICS ON
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS. THE
BOARD AND HCI WILL HAVE THE DATA
NECESSARY TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHERE CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS
CURRENTLY EXIST AND WHERE THEY
CAN POTENTIALLY BE CREATED. THE
INFORMATION WILL ALSO ASSIST THE
BOARD IN WORKING TO IDENTIFY
ADDITIONAL CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS IN A BROADER RANGE OF
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
CLINICS, NOT JUST ACUTE CARE.
GENERAL HOSPITALS. AS I'M
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS, I'M
CONFIDENT IF THE BILL IS VOTED
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
ALLOWED TO MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS, WE WILL RESOLVE AS MANY
OF THOSE CONCERNS AS WE CAN AND
THE CONSIDERATIONS OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS. WITH RESPECT TO
ENFORCEMENT, THAT WAS A
CONSCIOUS DECISION MADE NOT TO
PLACE ENFORCEMENT MEASURES IN
THE BILL AT THIS PARTICULAR
POINT OF TIME. ONE, FROM A
FUNDING AND COST STANDPOINT, IN
TERMS OF HCCI AND TWO, FRANKLY,
I WANTED TO SEE IF THE HEALTH
FACILITIES AND CLINICS WOULD
VOLUNTARILY REPORT THIS DATA
VOLUNTARILY IN THE SENSE THAT
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO IT, BUT
GET THE DATA IN AND THEN LET'S
SEE WHICH HEALTH FACILITIES AND
CLINICS, WHICH TYPE OF HEALTH
FACILITY OR CLINIC WAS HAVING
TROUBLE WITH THE DATA. AND IF
IT'S A PROBLEM WITH THE BILL,
WE'LL FIX THE BILL AS OPPOSED TO
SIMPLY HAVING A FINE PROCESS AND
WE START LEVYING FINES. SO WE
ARE WORKING TO REFINE THE
REPORTING TIME. IT WILL PROBABLY
BE ALMOST CERTAINLY BE AN ANNUAL
REPORT, I THINK, AT THIS POINT
IN TIME. AND THE QUESTION IS
WHEN WE REQUIRE THAT. OKAY.
SENATOR ROTH, AND YOU DON'T HAVE
LEAD WITNESSES WITH YOU? NOPE.
ALL RIGHT. THEN WE WILL ASK IF
THERE ARE FOLKS IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME
UP AND LET US KNOW THAT YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT. GO RIGHT AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAT
WAYLAND ELLISON WILSON HERE ON
BEHALF OF EUNUCH IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. GREAT.
THANK YOU. MORNING, DANIEL
PEARL, ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. TONY TRUJILLO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND OUR
CREDENTIALED SCHOOL NURSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL, THANK THE
AUTHOR. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. ARE THERE LEAD
WITNESSES WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD? IF YOU'RE NOT LEAD, BUT
YOU JUST WANT TO SAY A COUPLE OF
WORDS, THAT'S OKAY TO GO AHEAD.
WE ARE QUICKLY FIGHTING OVER WHO
WOULD NOT BE LEAD. YEAH, I CAN
SEE ROSHAMBO FOR NOT LEAD, BUT
GOT IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH ALEX
GRAVES, THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES, WE REPRESENT
90 ACCREDITED PRIVATE, NONPROFIT
COLLEGES IN THE STATE. WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. I WILL NOTE
THAT THAT LETTER WAS BASED ON
THE LANGUAGE PRIOR TO THESE MOST
RECENT AMENDMENTS, WHICH WE ARE
REVIEWING, BUT WOULD JUST
REITERATE OUR CORE POSITION ON
THIS, WHICH IS ONE WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE WORK
TO TRY AND GET BETTER PLACEMENT
DATA THAT WE COMPLETELY CONCUR
WITH AND THINK THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL IN THE BROADER
LANDSCAPE. OUR CONCERN REALLY
BOILS DOWN TO JUST ENSURING THAT
WE ARE NOT, INTENTIONALLY OR
UNINTENTIONALLY CREATING
PRIORITIZATION IN TERMS OF WHICH
PROGRAMS AND WHICH SEGMENTS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION, KIND OF GET
FIRST CRACK AT GETTING THOSE
NEEDS MET BECAUSE PLACEMENTS ARE
SOMETHING ALL NURSING PROGRAMS
AT CSUS UCS ARE PROGRAMS ARE ALL
TRYING TO GET MORE OF. AND SO
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR'S
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS SO FAR AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN RESOLVE THAT
MOVING FORWARD. GREAT. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS. I WOULD REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. I
DEFINITELY WANT TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENT OF MY COLLEAGUE, PRIOR
TO ME, THE GENERAL HAS DONE A
MASTERFUL JOB OF ACKNOWLEDGING
THE NUANCES OF OUR EIGHT
FREESTANDING CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS AND THE UNIQUE
REQUIREMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THEM, WITH THAT, ALTHOUGH WE ARE
CONCERNED WE HAVE THE UTMOST
FAITH THAT HE AND HIS STAFF WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US AND
WORK ON THOSE UNIQUE NUANCES. SO
I DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
GENERAL, FOR HIS WORK WITH THAT,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. YEAH,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. SARAH BRIDGE,
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
HERE, RESPECTFULLY, WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY ICU
AND THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS.
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS.
THANK YOU. GREAT. ALL RIGHT,
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, I'M. I AM MOST
IMPRESSED WITH THIS BECAUSE IT
WAS LAST YEAR. I THINK, WHEN YOU
AND I HAD DIFFERENT ROLES. WHEN
WE FIRST STARTED TALKING ABOUT
THIS BILL, WHICH WAS A SMALLER
ISSUE TO TRY TO GET AT EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
WHO GETS FIRST CRACK AT THOSE,
AT THOSE PLACEMENTS? WHO GETS
WHO GETS FIRST IN LINE, AND NOT
TO CREATE AN UNLEVEL PLAYING
FIELD. AND SO WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT AND YOU DECIDED WAS TO SAY
WE DON'T WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHERE THE PLACEMENTS ARE BEFORE
WE CAN SAY WHO GETS PRIORITIZED,
WHERE ARE THE PLACEMENTS AND HOW
MANY PLACEMENTS DO WE NEED, SO
I, I THINK IT'S MASTERFUL THE
WAY YOU'VE PUT IT TOGETHER TO
REALLY BACK UP AND TRY TO SOLVE
A PROBLEM, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
SOME OPPOSITION THAT SAYS IT
MIGHT BE DUPLICATIVE WITH WHICH
HCA IS ALREADY SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING SOME OF THIS KIND OF WORK?
WELL, HCCI DOES NOT COLLECT THIS
SPECIFIC DATA NUMBER ONE, IT'S
NOT REPORTED. THERE ARE SOME
REGIONAL CONSORTIA AROUND THE
STATE. THOSE TEND TO BE SORT OF
VOLUNTARY COLLABORATIONS. I'VE
NEVER YOU KNOW, I CHAIRED THIS
PARTICULAR COMMITTEE FOR THREE
YEARS AND WE CONDUCTED NUMEROUS
HEARINGS, SUNSET AND OTHERWISE,
WITH RESPECT TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING, THE NURSING
CRISIS IN THE STATE, THE
WORKFORCE ISSUES AND SCHOOL
ISSUES AND THE LIKE. AND I NEVER
SAW A REPORT OR ANY DATA COMING
OUT OF THE CONSORTIA THAT ONE OF
THE GROUPS MENTIONED. I'M NOT
CRITICIZING THAT. I THINK THAT'S
WONDERFUL. I THINK THERE'S ONE
IN ORANGE COUNTY, MAYBE IN THE
LA BASIN. IT'S A WONDERFUL
THING. BUT WE REALLY NEED TO DO
IT ON A MORE ORGANIZED,
REGIMENTED BASIS WITH SPECIFIC
DATA POINTS THAT ARE CORRELATED
BETWEEN THE BOARD AND HCCI
NUMBERS ARE CRUNCHED TO SEE
WHERE ADDITIONAL PLACEMENTS MAY
BE FOUND, BECAUSE THAT'S I'M
GOING TO MENTION IT IN THE
CLOSE, BUT THAT'S REALLY THE
FOCUS OF THE BILL, IS TO TRY TO
LOCATE ADDITIONAL CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS IN HOSPITALS. IF
THERE ARE ANY THAT STILL HAVE
NOT BEEN IDENTIFIED, BUT ALSO IN
CLINICS. FQHCS, OUTPATIENT
SURGERY CENTERS, WHERE WE'RE
STARTING WITH WITH HEALTH
FACILITIES AND CLINICS THAT ARE
LICENSED BY HCCI. BUT THERE ARE
A WHOLE VARIETY OF THOSE THAT
ARE NOT LICENSED BY HCCI. BUT
AGAIN, FROM A COST STANDPOINT,
WE TRIED TO LIMIT THIS TO,
FACILITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
LICENSED, THAT ALREADY HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH HCCI, WHERE
HCCI ALREADY COLLECTS SOME DATA.
AND THESE ARE ADDITIONAL DATA
POINTS TO ADD TO THE REPORT.
SPOKEN LIKE A GENERAL. I'LL MOVE
THE BILL WHEN THE. OTHER SENATOR
NILO. THE PROVISION OF THE DATA
COLLECTION OF COURSE, IS A VERY
POSITIVE ONE, BUT I'M TROUBLED
BY THE PRIORITIZATION ON, THE
BUREAU OF REGISTERED NURSING IS
A REGULATORY BODY THAT IS
REGULATING BROAD INDUSTRY, AND
IT'S NOT TYPICALLY OUR PRACTICE
FOR US TO DIRECT THAT, THAT A
REGULATORY BODY, PUT GIVE
PRIORITY TO SOME OF THE ENTITIES
THAT ARE REGULATED, BUT NOT ALL
OF THEM, OR INVOLVED. AND SO
I'M, I'M TROUBLED BY THE
PRIORITIZATION, THE REASON FOR
THE INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES OPPOSING THEM. I, I
TEND TO BE VERY SYMPATHETIC TO
THEIR ARGUMENTS AND HAVE TROUBLE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BECAUSE OF
THAT. CAN YOU RESPOND TO MY
DISCOMFORT? WELL, I THINK
THERE'S A FUNDAMENTAL
MISUNDERSTANDING IN THE IN IN
THE STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY OUT
THERE AS TO WHAT THE
PRIORITIZATION REALLY IS ALL
ABOUT. THE PRIORITIZATION, THE
FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS
PERMISSIVE. THE BOARD MAY OR MAY
NOT ELECT TO RESPOND TO REQUESTS
FOR ASSISTANCE BECAUSE ONCE
AGAIN, IN A PERFECT WORLD, I
WOULD HAVE REQUIRED THAT. BUT
IT'S A FUNDING ISSUE AND A
STAFFING ISSUE, AND SOMEBODY
WILL HAVE TO PAY FOR IT. EITHER
THE GENERAL FUND OR THE SCHOOLS
AND THE NURSES THAT ARE LICENSED
AND REGULATED BY THE BOARD. SO I
DECIDED TO MAKE IT PERMISSIVE.
AND THE PRIORITIZATION OAN HAS
TO DO WITH PRIORITIZING THE
REQUESTS FOR ASSISTANCE. SO IF
THEY GET TWO ONE FROM A PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT AND ONE FROM A PUBLIC
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, THE BILL
REQUIRES THE BOARD TO PRIORITIZE
THE REQUEST FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BEFORE MOVING. STAFFING
TO THE PRIVATE, FOR PROFIT
SCHOOLS REQUEST. AND THAT'S
CLEAR. AND THAT WAS SPECIFICALLY
INTENDED FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS. ONE, THE PRIVATE FOR
PROFITS, FOR EXAMPLE, TYPICALLY
HAVE ARE NOT RESOURCE CHALLENGED
. AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FREQUENTLY ARE OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS ARE RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE A BILL TO TRY TO MODIFY
THAT A LITTLE BIT, BUT RIGHT
NOW, PRODUCING ASSOCIATE DEGREE
NURSES WHERE THE HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES, BECAUSE
OF A NATIONAL MOVEMENT, ARE
PRIORITIZING BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
DEGREE NURSES IN TERMS OF THEIR
HIRING. SO RIGHT THERE, THERE IS
AN ISSUE. AND SO THE THOUGHT WAS
WE'LL GIVE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IF THERE IS ANY
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE BOARD TO
ASSIST, TO ASSIST THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, WITH RESPECT TO THEIR
CLINICAL PLACEMENT NEEDS, I WILL
I WILL SHARE WITH YOU ONE OF THE
OPPOSITION LETTERS. IN FACT,
THERE WERE A COUPLE THAT MADE
THE SAME POINT, TALKING ABOUT
THE BILL. THE BILL WOULD
INAPPROPRIATE URGE THE BRN TO
INTERFERE WITH DECISIONS BY
HEALTH FACILITIES ABOUT HOW MANY
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS THEY CAN
ACCOMMODATE AND WHEN, AS WELL AS
WHAT DEGREE CATEGORY OF NURSING
STUDENTS THEY SHOULD PRIORITIZE
FOR THOSE PLACEMENTS. SORT OF
SUPPORTING THE ARGUMENT FOR THE
BACHELOR OF SCIENCE DEGREE
PROGRAM AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SO OUR OUR HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES ARE PRIORITIZING THE
HIRING OF BSNS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. COLLEGES HISTORICALLY
HAVE HAVE PRODUCED ABOUT 40% OF
THE NURSING STUDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NURSES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO IT'S
A PRIORITY ONLY TO RESPOND TO
THE REQUEST FOR ASSISTANCE, NOT
TO PRIORITIZE PLACEMENT SLOTS
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR PUBLIC
OR THE CSUS. DOES THAT ANSWER?
ANSWER THE QUESTION, ARE YOU
GOOD THERE, SENATOR NILO? DO YOU
NEED IT? IT IS AN ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION. I DON'T FIND IT
ENTIRELY SATISFYING, THOUGH.
WELL, ALL DUE RESPECT. OKAY. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE DAIS?
ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
I THINK, SENATOR EGGMAN ALREADY
MADE A MOTION. ALL RIGHT, THEN,
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL.
WELL OH. I'M SORRY. OPPORTUNITY
TO CLOSE. I'M SORRY. YOU KNOW, I
CAN ONLY EMPHASIZE THAT, IT'S
ONLY A PRIORITY. IT'S ONLY TO
PRIORITIZE RESPONDING TO
REQUESTS FOR ASSISTANCE, NOT TO
DO ANYTHING ELSE. IT IS A
PERMISSIVE BILL, NOT A MANDATORY
BILL BY THE BOARD. I WILL TELL
YOU. AND I'M SURE YOU ALL KNOW,
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
HAS ABSOLUTELY NO AUTHORITY OVER
ANY HØI LICENSED HEALTH CARE
FACILITY OR CLINIC, AND NO
OPPORTUNITY TO TELL A HEALTH
CARE FACILITY OR A CLINIC ONE
SINGLE THING. THE BOARD'S
FUNCTION IN THIS UNDER THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS SIMPLY TO ACT
AS A FACILITATOR, TO TRY TO
BRING THE PARTIES, THE NURSING
SCHOOLS OR PROGRAMS AND THE
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
CLINICS TO THE TABLE TO DISCUSS
WHETHER THERE ARE ANY ADDITIONAL
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS
AVAILABLE, TO SATISFY THE NEEDS
OF NURSING STUDENTS IN THESE
PROGRAMS, I WILL TELL YOU IT'S
REFERENCED IN THE ANALYSIS, BUT,
SEMESTER AFTER SEMESTER, QUARTER
AFTER QUARTER, YEAR AFTER YEAR,
THERE ARE NURSING STUDENTS WHO
ARE ADMITTED OR ABOUT TO BE
ADMITTED INTO NURSING PROGRAMS
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL'S APPROVED
FOR 50 STUDENTS OR 100 STUDENTS,
AND THEY LOSE TEN CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS, THEY CAN'T EVEN
IN A NURSING CRISIS, THEY CANNOT
ADMIT A HUNDRED STUDENTS OR 50
STUDENTS. THEY ADMIT 40 OR 90
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOT WHEN YOU
ENTER THE PROGRAM. AND SO
HOWEVER WE DO THIS, A PLACEMENT
INVENTORY, AN ACCURATE PLACEMENT
INVENTORY THAT IS UTILIZED BY
SOMEONE TO ACT AS A FACILITATOR
TO PUT THE PARTIES TOGETHER AND
MATCH UP NEW CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS, IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL.
AND AS I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THIS,
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS TO
FOCUS ON NEW CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS, NOT TO REARRANGE THE DECK
CHAIRS WITH RESPECT TO SLOTS
THAT ARE ALREADY UTILIZED BY ONE
SCHOOL OR ANOTHER. AND WITH
THAT, THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO
ME AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. ALL RIGHT. NOW WE'LL
CALL THE ROLL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. MOTION DOES DO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ASHBY I ASHBY I WHEN
I WHEN I ALVARADO GIL I ALVARADO
GIL I ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I
BECKER DODD EGGMAN I EGGMAN I
GLAZER MENGIBAR NILO ROTH I ROTH
I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I WILK. THANK YOU. THAT'S
SEVEN. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL,
THOUGH. THAT IS ENOUGH. ALL
RIGHT. AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR HERE.
SENATOR DODD, I KNOW YOU HAVE
JUST ARRIVED, BUT ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT? DO YOU NEED
A MINUTE? ARE YOU GOOD? ALL
RIGHT. ALWAYS READY. THIS IS SB
1071 BY SENATOR DODD. LET'S GO.
WHEN YOU ARE READY, SENATOR. SB
1071. SO, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I AM PRESENTING SB
1071. IT'S A VERY, VERY SHORT
PRESENTATION. I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF ON AMENDMENTS. I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. GREAT.
THANK YOU. NO WITNESSES HERE FOR
THIS ONE OR THERE ARE. OKAY.
COME ON. FORWARD IF I WILL.
THOSE IN SUPPORT COME FORWARD.
AND, SEEING NONE THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. COME ON. FORWARD
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR. VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS, MIKE GENETSKI FOR THE
CONTRACTOR. STATE LICENSE BOARD.
I ORIGINALLY CAME TO COMMUNICATE
OPPOSE ON THE EXISTING TEXT, BUT
WITH THE AMENDMENT TO MIRROR SB
1455, A BILL, THE BOARD DOES
SUPPORT THE CONCERNS WITH THE
EXISTING LANGUAGE ARE ADDRESSED.
SO THE BOARD IS NOT OPPOSING.
1071 TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO SENATOR DODD. AND THE BOARD
IS HAPPY TO CONTINUE ITS WORK
WITH THE CHAIR, THE SENATOR AND
THE COMMITTEE ON THE ISSUE OF
SMALL CONTRACTOR BUSINESSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM? ALL
RIGHT, THEN, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DÍAS. ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS? ALL RIGHT THEN WHEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
GREAT I'LL MOVE THIS BILL, CALL
THE ROLE. MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ASHBY. HI. ASHBY.
AYE. WHEN AYE. WHEN? AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE ARCHULETA. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER. DODD
DODD. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER MENGIBAR. NILO. NILO
AYE. ROTH AYE. ROTH. AYE. SMALL
WITH CUEVAS. SMALL WITH CUEVAS.
AYE. WILK MADAM CHAIR NINE.
RIGHT. THAT'S NINE ZERO. HOLD
ON. ONE SECOND. YEAH. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
SENATOR ARCHULETA. YOU HAVE A
COMMENT. YOU WANT TO MOVE THE
BILL? IF YOU WERE NOT AUTHORIZED
TO MOVE THE BILL, IF THAT IS
TRUE, I WILL MOVE THE BILL. THAT
SOUNDS GREAT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP. WE'LL RECALL THE ROLL JUST
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NICE AND
CLEAR. CAN'T MOVE A BILL. AGAIN?
YEP. OKAY. WOW ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. WHEN? WHEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ABIGAIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. BECKER. DODD. AYE. DODD.
AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
MENGIBAR. NILO AYE. NILO. AYE.
ROTH. ROTH AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
AYE. RIVAS. AYE. WILK ALL RIGHT.
9 TO 0. KEEP IT CLEAN. PERFECT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ARCHULETA.
AND WE WILL MOVE ON. SENATOR
NILA, ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT FOR SENATOR WILK? I AM
ALL RIGHT. GREAT. LET'S DO IT.
WE'RE ON A ROLL. HELP ME KEEP
MOVING HERE. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1233, FROM SENATOR WILK, BUT
PRESENTED BY SENATOR NILO.
WHEN YOU ARE READY, SIR. MADAM
CHAIR, I WAS BORN READY. SECOND
TIME I'VE USED THAT LINE IN TWO
WEEKS. I APOLOGIZE, I AM,
PRESENTING SENATE BILL 1233 ON
BEHALF OF MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE, SENATOR WILK, WHO IS
OUT SOMEWHERE GOOFING OFF, JUST
JOKING, HE HAS A BUNCH OF
CONFLICTS TODAY, AND I'M HAPPY
TO DO THIS FOR HIM. AS YOU KNOW,
REDUCING PET OVERPOPULATION IN
SHELTERS IS A CRUCIAL PART OF
PREVENTING UNNECESSARY PET
EUTHANIZATIONS. TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS, SB 1233 CREATES THE FIRST
HIGH QUALITY, HIGH VOLUME SPAY
AND NEUTER CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
FOR VETERINARY STUDENTS AND
PROFESSIONALS TO BE ADMINISTERED
BY UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE AND WESTERN UNIVERSITY
COLLEGE OF VETERINARY MEDICINE
IN POMONA. HIGH QUALITY, HIGH
VOLUME SPAY AND NEUTER IS A
SURGICAL TECHNIQUE WHICH ENABLES
VETERINARIANS TO PERFORM
MINIMALLY INVASIVE PROCEDURES IN
A SAFE AND COST EFFECTIVE MANNER
. WHILE SOME VETS LEARN THIS
TECHNIQUE LATER IN THEIR CAREERS
, THERE IS CURRENTLY NO OFFICIAL
COURSE OFFERED BY VETERINARY
SCHOOLS TO TEACH THIS METHOD.
CONSIDERING THE SHORTAGE OF
VETERINARIANS AVAILABLE TO
PERFORM SPAY AND NEUTER
SERVICES, THIS PROGRAM WOULD
BENEFIT SHELTERS BY PROVIDING A
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE TECHNIQUE TO
ADDRESS UNWANTED BREEDING. BY
EMPLOYING THIS MORE EFFICIENT
METHOD IN A GREATER NUMBER OF
SHELTERS, PET OWNERS ACCESS TO
LOW AND NO COST SPAYS AND
NEUTERS WILL EXPAND
DRAMATICALLY. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL, AND THE
AUTHOR HAS BEEN ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH THE DEANS OF THE TWO
SCHOOLS FOR MONTHS TO DEVELOP
THE MEASURE. BEFORE YOU WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
DOCTOR GRANT MILLER, THE
REGULATORY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
SCHOOL ASSOCIATION. THÀNH, WHO
IS SPONSOR OF THE BILL, AND
DOCTOR SIPUM SIPERSTEIN COOK,
WHO IS A SHELTER VETERINARIAN AT
THE LOCAL SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SPCA. RIGHT HERE IN YOURS AND MY
DISTRICTS. MADAM CHAIR, THANK
YOU, SENATOR NIELLO, AND THANK
YOU. YEAH. WELCOME. YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANKS FOR
BEING HERE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ASHBY AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE, DOCTOR GRANT MILLER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. WE'RE VERY
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL. AND
AS SENATOR NIELLO MENTIONED, WE
REACHED OUT TO THE VETERINARY
SCHOOLS VERY EARLY ON TO TRY TO
TACKLE THE PROBLEM OF PET
OVERPOPULATION, TO SEE WHAT THE
VETERINARIANS AND THE
TECHNICIANS COULD DO TO DO THEIR
PART. AND THEY WERE VERY
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE CONCEPT
OF A OF A SPAY NEUTER
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. WESTERN
UNIVERSITY WANTS TO EXPAND THEIR
PROGRAM TO THE NORTH CENTRAL
ANIMAL SHELTER, WHICH IS IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES. THAT'S A
VETERINARY DESERT WHERE THERE'S
A GREAT NEED FOR THIS TYPE OF
SERVICE. UC DAVIS WANTS TO WORK
IN CONJUNCTION WITH YOLO COUNTY
ANIMAL SERVICES SO THAT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE SOCIOECONOMIC
CHALLENGES CAN CAN OBTAIN SOME
OF THESE, LOW COST OR NO COST,
HIGH QUALITY, HIGH VOLUME SPAY
NEUTER RESOURCES. SO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE PROSPECT OF
MAKING THIS PROGRAM GO. 60% OF
THE VETERINARY STUDENTS IN
SCHOOL WOULD LIKE TO, WELL, 100%
OF THEM WOULD LIKE TO DO THIS.
ONLY ABOUT 60% GET THE CHANCE TO
DO THIS. HIGH QUALITY, HIGH
VOLUME SPAY NEUTER. SO OUR GOAL
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
VETERINARIAN HAS THE ABILITY TO
DO IT. SO SHORT TERME BENEFIT
THAT WE CREATE TWO EPICENTERS
THAT THAT OFFER THESE SURGERIES,
TO THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE BOTH IN
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
. LONG TERME BENEFIT IS THAT OUR
VETERINARY WORKFORCE WILL BE
COMPETENT AT ALL OF US IN BEING
ABLE TO DO THIS. FOR SOME OF THE
OLD TIMERS LIKE ME, I CAN COME
BACK AND GET CERTIFIED. I CAN
TAKE IT AS CONTINUING EDUCATION
AND COME BACK AND LEARN THE
TECHNIQUES, AND I CAN TAKE A
SHIFT IN A SHELTER MYSELF. SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I'D LIKE TO GIVE
A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO DOCTOR
SAPERSTEIN COOK, WHO IS AN
EXPERT IN THIS AND GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
YEAH, SHE GETS TWO MINUTES AS
WELL. WELCOME. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. YES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, CHAIRPERSON MANN,
CHAIRPERSON ASHBY AND MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. I AM DOCTOR
LAURIE SAPERSTEIN COOK. AND I'M
THE CHIEF SHELTER MEDICINE
VETERINARIAN AT THE SACRAMENTO
SPCA, LAST YEAR ALONE, OUR
CLINIC SPAYED AND NEUTERED OVER
20,000 ANIMALS. DESPITE THESE
HIGH NUMBERS, WE HAVE A FIVE
MONTH WAITING LIST OF ANIMALS
NEEDING THESE SERVICES. I KNOW
THAT MANY OF OUR COUNTERPARTS IN
OTHER, OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
ARE EXPERIENCING THE SAME HIGH
DEMAND THAT WE ARE AND THAT'S
WHY WE ARE EXCITED THAT YOUR
COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TODAY, SINCE IT
WILL HELP TO FILL THE GAP IN THE
NUMBER OF QUALIFIED VETERINARY
PROFESSIONALS NEEDED TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY, HIGH VOLUME SPAY
AND NEUTER SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIA'S PET OWNERS. HIGH
QUALITY, HIGH VOLUME SPAY NEUTER
INVOLVES SPECIALIZED APPROACHES.
HAS BEEN SAID TO SPAYING AND
NEUTERING CATS AND DOGS. IT
FOCUSES ON REFINED SURGICAL
TECHNIQUES AND HIGHLY TRAINED
AND EFFICIENT PERSONNEL,
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY PATIENT
CARE. IN THIS SETTING, A
VETERINARY SURGEON CAN SAFELY
SPAY OR NEUTER UPWARDS OF 30
ANIMALS IN ONE DAY. HERE ARE
SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW WE ACHIEVE
THIS EFFICIENCY. WE MAKE VERY
SMALL INCISIONS. WE USE
STANDARDIZED DRUG PROTOCOLS FOR
THE MAJORITY OF OUR PATIENTS,
AND WE LIMIT OUR OWN PATIENTS TO
YOUNG AND HEALTHY ANIMALS, MOST
IMPORTANTLY BY CONSECUTIVE
REPETITION OF SPECIFIC
PROCEDURES, OUR SURGEONS DEVELOP
A VERY HIGH LEVEL OF PROFICIENCY
. IT'S A COMMON MISPERCEPTION,
INCLUDING AMONG SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE VETERINARY
COMMUNITY, THAT HIGH VOLUME MUST
MEAN LOW QUALITY. THIS COULDN'T
BE FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH. IN
FACT, THESE CLINICS ACTUALLY
EXPERIENCE A SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
COMPLICATION RATE THAN THE SAME
PROCEDURES IN PRIVATE PRACTICES.
IF THESE METHODS WERE TAUGHT IN
OUR VETERINARY SCHOOLS, IT WOULD
HELP NEW GRADUATES AND OTHERS TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE NUMBERS CAN
BE ACHIEVED WITHOUT SACRIFICING
PATIENT CARE. NOT ONLY WILL WE
BENEFIT FROM TRAINED SURGEONS IN
OUR CLINICS, BUT PRIVATE
PRACTITIONERS CAN INCORPORATE
THESE TECHNIQUES INTO THEIR
REGULAR PRACTICES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. PERFECT. RIGHT ON
TIME. GOOD JOB. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN THE ROOM WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT ME TO TESTIMONY. TELL US
YOUR NAME, ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING FIX OUR
SHELTERS AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS SACKETT FOR SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
DILLONLIAM. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION. SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ESTELLA DRAKE AND I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF OUR FUR BABIES, OUR
VOICELESS ANIMALS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. DEFINITELY IN
SUPPORT. AND THANK YOU FOR DOING
THIS. THANK YOU. NICE TO SEE
YOU. MISS DRAKE. LISA KIRK,
COMMUNITY CAT TRAPPER, 10,000
CATS AND 20 YEARS. DEFINITELY IN
SUPPORT. CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
450,000. ESTIMATED INDOOR
OUTDOOR CATS. NO LOW COST SPAY
AND NEUTER. THANK YOU. ANNUAL
ADULT FOUNDER AND CEO OF
AMERICAN RURAL HOMES AND
INVISIBLE PAWS RESCUE. AND WE
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THIS. WE NEED
US OUT MORE THAN EVER WITH
EVERYBODY TO HELP THE ANIMALS
OUT HERE WITH SPAY NEUTER,
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE WAITING
LIST IS SIX MONTHS OR LONGER,
AND WE'RE TALKING 3 OR 4 MORE
LAYERS IN TIME. THE SPCA RIGHT
ON TARGET. I SUPPORT THIS ALL
THE WAY. YOU AND THANKS FOR YOUR
GREAT WORK. A LOT OF SACRAMENTO
FOLKS IN THAT LINEUP GOT IT.
OKAY. ARE THERE ANY PEOPLE HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? IF
SO, NOW WOULD BE THE TIME TO
COME FORWARD. LEAD OR OTHERWISE.
NO. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DAIS. OKAY. IT'S
BEEN MOVED. SENATOR EGGMAN, JUST
A QUESTION. IN LOOKING THROUGH,
AND I KNOW THIS IS NOT YOUR
BILL. AND PERHAPS THE DOCTORS,
THERE IS TRAINING FOR THE TECHS
AS WELL AS FOR THE. THE DOCTORS
CAN BOTH PERFORM THE PROCEDURE.
DOES IT LOOK? WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
TO ME IS LIKE THE TECH CAN
PERFORM SOME OF THE LEAD UP, THE
ANESTHESIA AND STUFF, BUT NOT
THE ACTUAL PROCEDURES THAT.
CORRECT. THANK YOU, DOCTOR
EGGMAN. YES, THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION. SO THE WAY THIS BILL
IS STRUCTURED, IT WOULD UPHOLD
CURRENT STATE LAW, WHICH IS THAT
VETERINARIANS PERFORM THE
SURGICAL PROCEDURE ITSELF. BUT
WE CANNOT UNDERSCORE ENOUGH THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECHNICIAN AND
ENSURING THAT ALL OF THE
PRE-OPERATIVE AND POST-OPERATIVE
PROCEDURES ARE FOLLOWED, WHICH
INCLUDES, ACTUALLY, FOR THE TÊ,
SOME OF THE CLOSURE THAT'S DONE,
OUR VETS ARE ABSOLUTELY PIVOTAL
IN WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THIS
PROGRAM, AND THERE WILL BE ROOM
FOR TRAINING FOR THEM AS WELL.
OKAY. AND I AND I AND I KNOW YOU
PROBABLY WON'T LIKE THIS, BUT I
SAY IT EVERY TIME I GET AN
OPPORTUNITY. I THINK THEY CAN DO
THE SURGERIES AS WELL. I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF DOCUMENTATION.
AS FOR PEOPLE AND FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE THAT ADVANCED PEOPLE CAN DO
THESE KINDS OF THINGS, SO NOT,
NOT, NOT TODAY, NOT NOT THIS
YEAR. BUT GOING FORWARD, PEOPLE
KEEP THAT IN MIND. THANKS FOR
THOSE COMMENTS. IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION. WOULD YOU LIKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE SENATOR
NILO, ON BEHALF OF SENATOR WILK,
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR WILK, I
THANK THE WITNESSES IN FAVOR ALL
OF THEM. AND, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WE
HAVE OUR MOTION. I THINK THIS IS
Dð PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. IT IS
. WE'LL CALL THE ROLL. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. WHEN AYE. WHEN?
AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE ARCHULETA. HI.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER. DODD
DODD. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER MENGIBAR. NILO. AYE. AYE
WILK. EXCUSE ME. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK.
OKAY I THINK THAT'S EIGHT TO
NOTHING. IT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT,
BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN.
HOPEFULLY. SENATOR WILK SAYS
HERE TO VOTE ON HIS OWN BILL.
OKAY GREAT. PUT THAT ON CALL.
SENATOR NGUYEN, ARE YOU READY?
YOU GOT A COUPLE UP HERE? GOING
TO HEAR FROM SENATOR NGUYEN ON
SB 1459. AND THEN ON SB 1478.
WE'LL START WITH 1459. YOU KNOW,
THAT'S THE BURDEN OF. SENATOR
NGUYEN, WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. SB 1459 HAS
TWO EQUALLY IMPORTANT PARTS.
FIRST, IT WILL STANDARDIZE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
ANIMAL SHELTERS IN COUNTIES WITH
POPULATION GREATER THAN 400,000.
THIS IS INTENDED TO FACILITATE
EASY COMPARISONS BETWEEN THE
GOOD SHELTERS AND THE NOT SO
GOOD SHELTERS. IN AN EFFORT TO
STIMULATE COMPETITION AND
GENERATE PUBLIC PRESSURE FOR
IMPROVEMENTS BY SABAA SHELTERS,
SB 1459 REQUIRES ANIMAL SHELTERS
TO MONTHLY REPORT AND POST A
LIST OF BASIC DATA POINTS THAT
ARE INDICATIVE OF HOW THE
SHELTER IS MANAGED AND OPERATED.
SECOND, SB 1459 REMOVES ANY
AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW REQUIRING
THE TRAP NEUTER RETURN OR WHAT
THEY CALL A TNR. PROGRAMS. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
WAYS TO REDUCE THE POPULATION OF
FERTILE OR COMMUNITY CATS. IN
THOSE PROGRAMS, INDIVIDUAL CATS,
CATS AND HAVE THEM STERILIZED
AND THEN RETURN THEM TO THE
LOCATION WHERE THEY WERE CAUGHT.
PENAL CODE SECTION 597 MAKES IT
A CRIME TO BAN ANY ANIMAL. SOME
COUNTIES HAVE CURTAILED THEIR
TNR PROGRAMS IN FEAR THAT THE
PARTICIPANTS MIGHT BE CHARGED
WITH ANIMAL ABANDONMENT UNDER
THE PENAL CODE. OTHERS ARE
RELUCTANT TO INSTITUTE SUCH
PROGRAMS FOR THE SAME REASON, SO
SB 1459 CLARIFIES THAT PERSONS
PARTICIPATING IN IN TNR PROGRAMS
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE PROVISION
OF PENAL CODE SECTION 597.
CURRENTLY THERE IS A SIMILAR
PROVISION THAT EXEMPTS FISH AND
WILDLIFE WORKERS WHO TRAP AND
RELEASE WILD ANIMALS IN THE
REGULAR COURSE OF THEIR WORK,
FROM BEING GUILTY OF ANIMAL
ABANDONMENT. I ALSO HAVE HERE
WITH ME, MADAM CHAIR, IS DOCTOR
KATE HURLEY, DIRECTOR OF UC
DAVIS COURT SHELTER MEDICINE
PROGRAM, THE FIRST SUCH PROGRAM
OF ITS KIND IN THE COUNTRY. HERE
TO TESTIFY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS WELL. GREAT. THANK
YOU. SENATOR NGUYEN. YOU HAVE A
COUPLE MINUTES. THANKS FOR BEING
HERE. THANKS. GOOD MORNING. I'M
DOCTOR KATE HURLEY, AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE UC DAVIS KORET
SHELTER MEDICINE PROGRAM. AND I
SPEAK TODAY WITH RESPECT TO
SECTION TWO OF SB 1459, WHICH
RELATES TO PENAL CODE 597 S AND
WOULD MAKE EXISTING LAW CLEAR
THAT STERILIZATION AND RETURN OF
COMMUNITY CATS DOES NOT
CONSTITUTE CRIMINAL ABANDONMENT.
FOR OVER 20 YEARS, I HAVE
STUDIED AND CONSULTED ON METHODS
TO MANAGE THE MANY FREE ROAMING
CATS FOUND IN VIRTUALLY EVERY
COMMUNITY. THE MOST PRACTICAL
AND HUMANE STRATEGY IS KNOWN AS
TRAP, NEUTER, RETURN OR TNR, AND
INVOLVES RETURNING CATS TO THEIR
OUTDOOR HOMES AFTER A QUICK VET
EXAM AND STERILIZATION. THIS
MAKES THE INDIVIDUAL CATS MUCH
HEALTHIER, REDUCES NUISANCE
BEHAVIORS, ELIMINATES
REPRODUCTION, PREVENTS THE
VACUUM EFFECT ASSOCIATED WITH
REMOVAL, AND PROVIDES AN
ALTERNATIVE FOR CATS THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD BE EUTHANIZED AT
ANIMAL SHELTERS. UNDER THIS
BILL, SECTION TWO WOULD MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT TNR DOES NOT
CONSTITUTE CRIMINAL ABANDONMENT
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION THAT
WILL ALLOW TNR TO BE ADDED TO
THE TOOLBOX OF MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES FOR THOSE WHO
PREVIOUSLY MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
SURE OF ITS LEGALITY AND ON A
PERSONAL NOTE, I WORKED AS AN
ANIMAL CONTROL OFFICER FOR FIVE
YEARS BEFORE ENTERING VET
SCHOOL, AND IN ADDITION TO
ENFORCING PENAL CODE 597 ON
ANIMAL ABANDONMENT, I PICKED UP
AND BROUGHT COMMUNITY CATS INTO
THE ANIMAL SHELTER, AND I
EUTHANIZED THEM MYSELF. IF WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO PLACE THEM FOR
ADOPTION. SO I KNOW IT WOULD
HAVE MEANT THE WORLD TO ME TO BE
ABLE TO SEE THOSE CATS
STERILIZED AND RETURNED INSTEAD.
AND I THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
THIS LEGISLATION. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY, SENATOR
NGUYEN, NO OTHER LEAD, NO
SUPPORTERS. OKAY, SO ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT WHO'D LIKE
TO ME TO TESTIMONY COME FORWARD,
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. DILLON
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION, CURRENTLY
SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED FOR THE
REASONS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS
. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO DO WE HAVE OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM? OKAY. IF THERE'S A
IF THERE'S A LEAD OPPOSITION
ONLY SEE EVERYBODY CAN'T TALK
FOR TWO MINUTES. BUT IF YOU THE
FIRST PERSON MAYBE HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES TO MAKE YOUR OPPOSITION
ARGUMENT GO RIGHT AHEAD.
ABSOLUTELY. SO I'M KIND OF A
TWEENER. SO, MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS, WE I REPRESENT FIX OUR
SHELTERS. MONICA MILLER. AND WE
HAVE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED.
WE'VE HAD SOME GREAT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SENATOR'S
STAFF. WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THOSE. DEFINITELY WANT TO WORK
ON THE DEFINITION OF COMMUNITY
CATS. THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT, BUT AGAIN,
THANK YOU. AND THE SENATOR AND
HER STAFF AND YOUR STAFF AT THE
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. GREAT READ. HELLO. GOOD
MORNING OR AFTERNOON, MY NAME IS
SHARON LOGAN. I AM A CONSTITUENT
OF JANICE NGUYEN. I LIVE IN HER
DISTRICT. I CAME DOWN HERE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY TODAY, I
SUCCESSFULLY SUED OC ANIMAL CARE
IN 2014 FOR THEIR HIGH
EUTHANASIA RATES. SO AS IT IS,
AS IT IS WRITTEN, THIS BILL IS A
LICENSE TO DUMP ANIMALS. THIS
BILL CAN AND MUST BE AMENDED
DESPITE EXCELLENT INTENTIONS. AS
WRITTEN, THE BILL WILL CREATE
HORRIFIC UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
CAUSING MORE SUFFERING THAN IT
PREVENTS. COMMUNITY CAT
DEFINITION IS FAR TOO
OVERINCLUSIVE THE TERMS
COMMUNITY CATS CAN TOO EASILY
INCLUDE CATS WHO ARE OWNED OR
ADOPTABLE, OR WHO LACK THE
SKILLS TO SURVIVE ON THEIR OWN
OUTDOORS. THERE'S CURRENTLY A
PENDING LAWSUIT AGAINST SAN
DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY BECAUSE WE
HAVE DOCUMENTED EVIDENCE OF CATS
SUFFERING HORRIFIC TRAGEDIES AND
DEATH BECAUSE OF THE SHELTER
ABANDONED, THESE NON-FATAL, ILL,
HEALTHY CATS UNDER THE COMMUNITY
CAT PROGRAM. NO ENVIRONMENTAL,
NO ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT
HAS BEEN DONE TO DETERMINE THE
IMPACT ON LOCAL WILDLIFE OR THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT FOR THIS NEW
OVERINCLUSIVE DEFINITION OF
COMMUNITY. CAT. THIS IS A LAW.
THIS THUS THIS LAW IS RIPE FOR
LEGAL CHALLENGE. HISTORICALLY,
TNR HAS BEEN FOR FERAL CATS. IF
THE BILL'S TRUE CONCERN IS THAT
SHELTERS ARE AFRAID TO IMPLEMENT
TNR, THEN THE LAW SHOULD BE
AMENDED TO SERVE THAT STATED
PURPOSE THAT THE LAW SHOULD BE
REWRITTEN TO PROVIDE THAT TNR,
TNR FOR FERAL CATS DOES NOT
CONSTITUTE ABANDONMENT UNDER PC
597, BUT DO NOT EXPAND THIS
CONCEPT OF TNR TO INCLUDE CATS
LACKING THE ABILITY TO FIND
THEIR OWN FOOD, WATER, OR
SHELTER. CURRENTLY I'M OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL, BUT IF IT MAY BE
WRITTEN OR AMENDED TO SPECIFY
SPECIFY. THIS IS ONLY FOR FERAL
CATS OR TRUE COMMUNITY CATS. NOT
HEALTHY, ADOPTABLE, NON FERAL
FRIENDLY CATS THAT SHOULD BE
ADOPTED OUT BY THE SHELTER. I
WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE IN LINE,
WE'RE AT THE METOO TESTIMONY
NOW. SO WE CAN'T READ A
STATEMENT. IT'LL BE YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. OKAY. GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DAN ADERHOLT.
I'M VOEPEL PAUL'S RESCUE HOMES.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT NEEDS TO BE AMENDED ON
CERTAIN THINGS. THANK YOU.
GREAT. THANK YOU. YEAH. MY NAME
IS WENDY ARAGON WITH
REPRESENTING PET ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION. WE WERE FOUNDED IN
1955 TO ADDRESS THE TRAGEDY OF
PET OVERPOPULATION. AND HERE WE
ARE TODAY. AND I BELIEVE THIS
BILL IS IT DOESN'T REALLY DEAL
WITH THE PROBLEM OF PET
OVERPOPULATION. SO YOU OPPOSE
NOW, BUT WE OPPOSE. OKAY.
OPPOSE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT.
HELLO, NICHOLAS HAGGARD, FOR
SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION OPPOSED ON THE
COMMUNITY CAT PIECE. THANK YOU.
OKAY MY NAME IS CLAUDIA CARDOZA,
AND I REPRESENT ANIMAL NETWORK
WELFARE ALLIANCE GROUP. I OPPOSE
CURRENTLY, BUT WITH FEW
AMENDMENTS IN THE WORDING, OKAY.
IN THE FUTURE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ESTELLA DRAKE.
AND I AM THE VOICE FOR THE
VOICELESS ANIMALS OF CALIFORNIA,
AND I. I'M 5050 HERE, AND I
THINK IT JUST NEEDS TO BE
CLEANED UP. BUT WE CAN. YOU GUYS
CAN MAKE IT HAPPEN. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LISA KIRK, COMMUNITY CAT TRAPPER
. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT AMENDED
THE COMMUNITY CAP. DESCRIPTION.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO TALK SOME OF
THE AUTHORS ABOUT WHAT ACTUALLY
YOU'RE OPPOSED FOR NOW BUT
LOOKING FOR AMENDMENTS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL. THAT'S IT FOR
FOLKS TESTIFYING IN THE ROOM.
GOT IT. SOUNDS LIKE PRETTY CLEAR
DIRECTION. ANYBODY FROM THE DAIS
HAVE ANY COMMENTS? OKAY. GO
AHEAD, SENATOR ALVARADO GILL.
SENATOR NGUYEN WOULD YOU BRIEFLY
JUST SPEAK ON SOME OF THE
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION IN
TERMS OF YOUR WILLINGNESS OR
ABILITY TO TAKE AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE THIS BILL MORE PALATABLE
FOR SOME OF THE OPPOSITION? I
THINK I MEAN, WE'RE OPEN TO
WORKING WITH ORGANIZATIONS,
INDIVIDUALS TO LOOK AT WHAT WE
CAN WORK ON THE REASON FOR THE,
THE LEGISLATION OR THE TNR IS
PART IS THAT RIGHT NOW, SHELTERS
ARE NOT A LOT OF SHELTERS ARE
NOT ACCEPTING ANY CATS BEING
TURNED INTO THE SHELTERS. AND SO
WHAT YOU'RE HAVING IS THAT
INSTEAD IS THERE'S THEY'RE GOING
TO THEY'RE JUST RELEASE OUT
THERE. BUT IT'S OVERPOPULATION
IS THE CAUSE AT THIS TIME. AND
SO IF, IF WE CAN ALLOW SHELTERS
TO ACCEPT THESE CATS FERTILE OR
COMMUNITY CATS, THEN THEY CAN AT
LEAST NEUTER IT. AND IF THEY'RE
NOT ADOPTABLE, THEY CAN RELEASE
IT BACK TO THE COMMUNITY WHERE
IT WAS IT CAME FROM VERSUS RIGHT
NOW, A LOT OF SHELTERS ARE NOT
EVEN ALLOWED, URGING YOU TO
BRING IN ANY FERTILE OR
COMMUNITY CLASS CATS INTO THE
INTO THE SHELTERS AT ALL. OKAY,
I JUST HAVE ONE COMMENT. I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD IN THERE, BUT I'D LOVE FOR
YOU TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPONENTS, PARTICULARLY ON THAT
DEFINITION OF FERAL CAT VERSUS
ADOPTABLE CAT. SO IF YOU CAN
WORK ON THAT, YOU GOT A LITTLE
MORE TIME. SHE'S GOT SOME MORE
COMMITTEES TO GO, AND YOU CAN
TALK TO THE SOME OF THE FOLKS
THAT SHOWED UP HERE TODAY. I
THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE BROAD
SUPPORT BY THE END. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. NEED A MOTION? THE
BILL SO MOVED BY SENATOR NILO, I
THINK THIS IS GOING TO APPROPS
NEXT WE'LL CALL. THE ROLL MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ASHBY I ASHBY I NGUYEN I RAN I
ALVARADO GIL I ALVARADO GIL I
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I BECKER
DODD DODD I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GLASER. GLASER I MENGIBAR NILO I
NILO I ROTH. ROTH I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK. I THINK NINE.
RIGHT. WE'LL GET. IT'S NINE
ZERO, SO IT'S ENOUGH, BUT WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL ANYWAY. SENATOR
NGUYEN, FOR OUR COLLEAGUES WHEN
THEY COME BACK AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO YOUR NEXT BILL, SB 1478. ARE
YOU READY? YES. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, COLLEAGUES, SB 1478
PROVIDES GUIDANCE TO
VETERINARIANS WHO PRACTICE IN
ANIMAL SHELTERS BY OUTLINING
BASIC BUT ESSENTIAL ELEMENTS
NECESSARY FOR THE PROPER AND
SAFE CARE OF ANIMALS THAT ARE
BEING HOUSED IN ANIMAL SHELTERS.
THIS WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
A FEW MONTHS AGO, WHEN I WAS
LOOKING INTO THE DIFFERENT
SHELTERS. THERE ARE ANIMALS OUT
THERE LIKE AN EXAMPLE I WAS
SHOWN WAS A HUSKY WHO WAS
INJURED AND BASICALLY BLEED TO
DEATH FOR THREE DAYS IN THE
SHELTER. THERE IS NO RECORD OF
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE DOG.
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO MEDICAL
RECORD, NOTHING ON THE DOG. I
MEAN, NOT EVEN A RECORD TO SHOW
THAT HE WAS GIVEN ANY PAIN MEDS.
THEN THERE'S A CAT, A KITTEN WHO
HAD HALF A LIMB LEFT AND WAS
BLEEDING, BUT THERE WAS NO CARE.
THERE'S NOTHING THERE THAT
ANYBODY KNEW ABOUT. AND SO THIS
IN ITSELF BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION BY LOTS OF VOLUNTEERS.
AND THIS IS HOW THIS BILL WAS
BORN. WAS THAT ANIMAL CARE AND
SHELTERS VARIES WIDELY. AND
THERE HAVE BEEN REPORTS OF
INEXCUSABLE CONDITIONS AND
AVOIDABLE ANIMAL OUTCOMES IN
SEVERAL ANIMAL SHELTERS IN
CALIFORNIA, SB 17, I'M SORRY,
1478 PLACES IN STATUTE A
TEMPLATE FOR ANIMAL CARE THAT
CONTAINS THE FOLLOWING ELEMENTS
ONE. TIME PERIODS WITHIN WHICH
ANIMALS MUST BE ASSESSED AT
INTAKE AND REGULARLY MONITOR TWO
TWO PROTOCOLS FOR TREATING
COMMON MEDICAL CONDITIONS. THREE
PROTOCOLS FOR CONDITION FOR
CONTROLLING INFECTIOUS DISEASES
AND PREVENTING ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION FOUR HOW TO MANAGE
ACUTE PAIN FIVE. COMMUNICATION
STANDARDS BETWEEN TECHNICIANS
AND VETERINARIANS. AND THIS IS
SO CRITICAL BECAUSE SOME
SHELTERS AND WHEN YOU HEAR FROM
THE VOLUNTEERS THAT
COMMUNICATION IS NOT HAPPENING.
AND A LOT OF TIMES THE
TECHNICIAN SEES THESE ANIMALS
AND CAN GET THE ATTENTION OF
VETERINARIANS AND SOMETIMES VICE
VERSA. AND THAT'S NOT HAPPENING
IN SIX CRITERIA FOR MEDICALLY
RELATED EUTHANIZATION CASES. AND
AT THIS TIME, WE ALSO HAVE
DOCTOR KATE HURLEY, WHO ALSO
SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL. ALL
RIGHT. OR ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS. THAT'S I DIDN'T
PREPARE ANY REMARKS ON THAT ONE,
BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
WE MAY HAVE. THAT'S GREAT. OKAY.
ARE THERE FOLKS HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE IN SUPPORT WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COME FORWARD? GO AHEAD
AND, YOU CAN JUST GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
WE'LL MOVE THROUGH THIS ONE
PRETTY QUICKLY. GO AHEAD. HELLO.
THANK YOU AGAIN. SHARON LOGAN
OUT OF ORANGE COUNTY. I DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. I DO THINK
TRANSPARENCY IS NEEDED IN ALL
OUR SHELTERS. AND I THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ESTELLA DRAKE, THE VOICE FOR THE
VOICELESS ANIMALS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE THESE
ANIMALS NEED OUR HELP. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. HELLO AGAIN,
DANIEL HOLMES CREW AND INVISIBLE
PAWS RESCUE NONPROFIT. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE
ANIMALS DEFINITELY NEED OUR
HELP. BIG TIME. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
CLAUDIA CARDOZA, ANIMAL NETWORK
WELFARE ALLIANCE, WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT. ARE THERE
ANY FOLKS IN THE ROOM WHO OPPOSE
THE BILL? NOW WOULD BE THE TIME
TO COME FORWARD. SEEING NO ONE
WILL COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES ANYTHING HERE? ALL
RIGHT, THEN, MOVED BY SENATOR
NILA, WOULD YOU LIKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE? SENATOR
NGUYEN, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. AYE. SUPPORT ALL RIGHT. WE
HAVE A MOTION. THIS IS ALSO Dð
PASS TO APPROPRIATE. WE'LL CALL
THE ROLL. ASHBY. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
WHEN I, WHEN I ALVARO. GIL
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER DODD.
DODD. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. MENGIBAR. NILO ELI.
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK. I THINK THAT'S 8 TO
0. THAT'S ENOUGH. BUT WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR YOU.
SENATOR NGUYEN, I NEED TO TRADE
PLACES WITH YOU SO THAT I CAN
PRESENT FOUR BILLS. ARE YOU UP
FOR IT? THESE ARE OUR COMMITTEE
BILLS. LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GET
THROUGH THEM QUICKLY AND GET
EVERYBODY OUT OF HERE.
SHE'S HUSTLING TO HER SEAT.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH 1451
WITNESSES. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. PLEASE GO FOR IT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. I AM
HERE TO PRESENT SB 1451. IT'S
THE ANNUAL BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
CODE OMNIBUS BILL THAT MAKES
VARIOUS CHANGES TO THE PRACTICE
ACTS OF A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS,
PROGRAMS WHICH HAVE RECENTLY
BEEN SUBJECT TO THE COMMITTEE'S
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT PROCESS.
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY CONTAINS
PROVISIONS THAT EMPOWER FEMALE
DOMINANT HEALTH PROFESSIONS TO
SAFELY AND SUCCESSFULLY INCREASE
ACCESS TO CARE FOR CALIFORNIA
PATIENTS. SB 1451 ALLOWS A
REGISTERED DENTAL HYGIENIST IN
ALTERNATIVE PRACTICE, TO
CONTINUE SERVING PATIENTS IN AN
OFFICE, EVEN IF A DENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREA
DESIGNATION IS REMOVED. I'M
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
HYGIENIST, CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER IMPORTANT
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT WE
MAXIMIZE COLLABORATION BETWEEN
PROVIDERS AND CONNECT PATIENTS
TO QUALITY CARE. THE BILL ALSO
ELIMINATES BARRIERS TO NURSE
PRACTITIONERS PRACTICING
INDEPENDENTLY BY MAKING VARIOUS
CLARIFYING CHANGES IN THE
PROCESS. YOU DON'T NEED ME TO
TELL YOU THIS, BUT WHERE THINGS
STAND IN OUR STATE'S ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE PRIMARY CARE
TO MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WITHOUT ACCESS, THESE WOMEN ARE
EDUCATED, TRAINED, AND HAVE
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE TO SAFELY
AND EFFECTIVELY PLAY A KEY PART
IN OUR OVERALL HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. SB 1451 REFINES
PROVISIONS IN THE MEDICAL
PRACTICE ACT TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT MEDICAL
DOCTORS AND OSTEOPATHIC DOCTORS
CANNOT CALL THEMSELVES DOCTOR OR
GIVE THE IMPRESSION THAT THEY
ARE A PHYSICIAN, PARTICULARLY IN
A HEALTH FACILITY LIKE A
HOSPITAL. THIS IS A SIMPLE AND
FAIR PROTECTION TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE PUT IN HOURS OF
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TO ATTAIN
THIS TITLE. THIS BILL ALSO MAKES
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTICE ACT TO
AUTHORIZE LICENSED VOCATIONAL
NURSES TO HAVE, WHO HAVE MET
CERTAIN TRAINING AND EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT CAN PROVIDE
LIMITED RESPIRATORY SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS IN A VERY
LIMITED AND SPECIFIC SETTINGS.
THE BILL ALSO UPDATES LANGUAGE
IN THE BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
ACT TO CLARIFY THAT A
HAIRSTYLIST LICENSE FEE IS THE
SAME AS OTHER BEAUTIFICATION
SERVICE PROVIDERS. SB 1451
ADDITIONALLY MAKES CHANGES TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL.
CONTINUING EDUCATION THÀNH.
OBVIOUSLY, I DID NOT BRING YOU
EXPERTS IN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE AREAS. SO WITH ME IN
SUPPORT TODAY IS KRISTY DE
LEMOS, THE CHIEF OF ADVANCED
PRACTICE AT UC DAVIS MEDICAL
CENTER. ELENA FRANCISCO, PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
PACIFIC'S REGISTERED DENTAL
HYGIENISTS IN ALTERNATIVE
PRACTICE PROGRAMS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB 1451, OUR OMNIBUS
BILL, PLEASE, BEFORE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES EACH. I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S WORKING. YEP. I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR ASHBY AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL 1451. MY NAME IS
CHRISTY DELEMUS, AND I'M AN
ACUTE CARE NURSE PRACTITIONER. I
COMPLETED MY TRAINING AT UCSF IN
2002 AND BEGAN MY CAREER WORKING
WITH A TEAM OF PHYSICIANS CARING
FOR PATIENTS WITH ACUTE STROKE,
ACUTE CARE NURSE PRACTITIONERS,
WORK IN HOSPITALS AND HOSPITAL
BASED CLINICS WHERE PROVIDER
SHORTAGES ARE IMPACTFUL. I WORK
AT UC DAVIS HEALTH AS THE CHIEF
OF ADVANCED PRACTICE, AND I
OVERSEE 458 ADVANCED PRACTICE
PROVIDERS BECAUSE I'M IN A
LEADERSHIP ROLE, I FOLLOWED
ABOUT 90 VERY CLOSELY. I STILL
REMEMBER BEING ON THE PUBLIC
CALL WITH THE BURN WHEN I
LEARNED THAT I WOULD BE EXCLUDED
FROM LICENSING TO PRACTICE AS A
103 NURSE PRACTITIONER, I'VE
WORKED AS A NURSE PRACTITIONER,
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY CARE FOR
22 YEARS TO BE EXCLUDED, WHILE
PEOPLE THAT I TRAINED WERE ABLE
TO BE LICENSED WAS A
DISAPPOINTMENT. BUT I'M NOT
ALONE. THERE ARE MANY ADVANCED
PRACTICE NURSES WHOSE BOARD
CERTIFICATION WAS RETIRED, WHO
WERE IN THE SAME SITUATION THAT
I AM IN. AN EXAM THAT I TOOK
MORE THAN 20 YEARS AGO DOES NOT
DEFINE MY LEVEL OF EXPERIENCE OR
MY COMMITMENT TO SAFE PATIENT
CARE, INCLUDING ADVANCED
PRACTICE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCED WITH THIS CLEANUP
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
PRACTICE TO TOP OF SCOPE AND
HELP CREATE ACCESS TO CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE.
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ARE STRUGGLING WITH DELAYS IN
CARE THAT ARE OFTEN RELATED TO
TOO FEW PROVIDERS. NOW IS THE
TIME TO USE EVERY TEAM MEMBER
TO. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. IS
THIS ON? YEP THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ELENA
FRANCISCO. I LIVE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN STOCKTON AND SPENT
MOST OF MY 48 YEARS PRACTICING
DENTAL HYGIENE AND TEACHING IN
STOCKTON, CALIFORNIA, I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DAP PROGRAM AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF THE PACIFIC,
ARTHUR DUGONI SCHOOL OF
DENTISTRY, AND I'M ALSO AN RDP.
THERE IS A GREAT NEED FOR WRAPS
TO PROVIDE PATIENT CARE IN THE
MANY DENTAL DESERTS IN
CALIFORNIA. AN WRAP IS A DENTAL
HYGIENIST WHO IS EDUCATED AND
LICENSED TO PROVIDE DENTAL
HYGIENE CARE IN AREAS THAT LACK
ACCESS TO CARE TO DENTAL CARE,
WE TREAT PATIENTS WITH PHYSICAL
AND OR COGNITIVE DISABILITIES IN
THEIR RESIDENCE. SCHOOLS
RESIDENTIAL AND OTHER LIVING
FACILITIES, DENTAL OFFICES, AND
IN FREESTANDING DENTAL HYGIENE
OFFICES IN DENTAL HEALTH,
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREAS WRAP
ARE A VITAL LINK BETWEEN THESE
PATIENTS AND THE DENTAL HOME. WE
CONNECT PATIENTS TO A DENTIST
WHO IS WILLING TO TREAT THEM. ÁP
C PATIENTS, REGARDLESS OF
INSURANCE. WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
OUR PRACTICE, DENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS, SHORTAGE AREAS OR
DISEASE ARE ARE AREAS OF THAT
LACK DENTAL PROFESSIONALS IN
RELATION TO THE POPULATIONS
THEY'RE FOUND IN. URBAN RURAL,
AND SUBURBAN SETTINGS. MANY OF
THE RURAL RESIDENTS IN MY AREA
HAVE DIFFICULTY ACCESSING DENTAL
CARE. WE NEED ALL TYPE OF DENTAL
PROVIDERS IN DENTAL DESERTS. WE
SUPPORT AMENDING THE STATUTE TO
GRANDFATHER IN WRAPS WITH BRICK
AND MORTAR PRACTICES. IF THE IF
THE DESIGNATION IS REMOVED,
ALLOWING WRAPS TO CONTINUE TO
SEE PATIENTS IN THESE AREAS.
THIS FIX WILL REMOVE BARRIERS TO
WRAPS WHO ARE INVESTING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL 1451.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME, IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT, PLEASE
COME UP. STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
JENNIFER TANNEHILL WITH AARON
REED AND ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENIST
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT, MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS DARBY KERNAN FOR
LEADINGAGE, CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WELL, I
ASKED THE GUY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ORTHODONTISTS.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THE BILL
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED, BUT WE'LL
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
BOARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MATT
LÀ, ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA
, WITH THESE AMENDMENTS, WE MOVE
TO THE SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI.
MY NAME IS KENNY CHAN. I'M A 103
FAMILY NURSE PRACTITIONER, AND I
WORK FOR LA COUNTY HEALTH
SERVICES, AND I SUPPORT THE BILL
. PATTI GURNEY, IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS, AND WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. I'M DANNY
CEDARS, DIRECTOR OF ADVANCED
PRACTICE AT UC DAVIS HEALTH AND
AN ACUTE CARE NURSE PRACTITIONER
OF 12 YEARS IN EMERGENCY
MEDICINE AND PULMONARY CRITICAL
CARE. AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
FERRYBRIDGE, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. VANESSA GONZALEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING JUSTIN.
FANS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF NURSE
ANESTHESIOLOGY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE GORDILLO. I'M AN ÁP
AND CO-FOUNDER OF SMILE
ESSENTIALS DENTAL HYGIENE
PRACTICE, AND I'M HERE IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CYNTHIA DILLON
REGISTERED DENTAL HYGIENIST AND
ALTERNATIVE PRACTICE AND
CO-FOUNDER OF SMILE ESSENTIALS
IN HAYWARD, IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JESSICA MORAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE A BIT OF A TWEENER, BUT WE
ARE OPTIMISTIC ABOUT ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT RDP LICENSURE
AND OUR ONGOING CONCERNS, HOPING
WE CAN GET TO A PLACE AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO MORE
SUPPORT, IS THERE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS DOCTOR ELISA
CICERONE. I'M A LICENSED
NATUROPATHIC DOCTOR, AND I'M THE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NATUROPATHIC DOCTORS ASSOCIATION
. AND WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND YOUR STAFF FOR
PROPOSING AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT NATUROPATHIC DOCTORS ARE
STILL ABLE TO USE THE TITLE OF
DOCTOR. AS LONG AS WE CONTINUE
TO USE THE ACCURATE DESIGNATION
OF MD AFTER OUR NAME, WITHOUT
THESE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS, SB
1451 WOULD REMOVE THE ABILITY OF
LICENSED NATUROPATHIC DOCTORS TO
IDENTIFY OURSELVES AS DOCTORS,
DESPITE HAVING DOCTORAL LEVEL
TRAINING AND LICENSING AS
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BROAD WAY IN
WHICH THE TERMS REASONABLE
PATIENT COULD BE INTERPRETED AND
USED TO LAUNCH INVESTIGATIONS
INTO DOCTORS WHO ARE PRACTICING
WITHIN THEIR SCOPE. WE
UNDERSTAND THIS MAY NOT BE THE
INTENTION OF THE BILL, BUT
MULTIPLE LEGAL OPINIONS INDICATE
THAT THIS COULD BE AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE. SO BECAUSE OF THESE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS, WE REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF TO SOLIDIFY THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. GEORGE.
STORIES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. WE DO NOT
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION AND A
BIT OF A, YOU KNOW, KIND OF
MIXED VIEWS ON SOME OF THE STUFF
IN THE BILL, BUT APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR AND ALL
THE STAFF HERE AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. BUT WE HAVE
CONCERNS SPECIFICALLY RELATING
TO THE PROVISIONS AROUND THE
THREE YEAR TRANSITION TO
PRACTICE FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. THE THREE YEAR
TRANSITION WAS INCLUDED TO
ENSURE CLINICAL COMPETENCY, THèC
FOR INDEPENDENT PRACTICE AND
JUST FOR BEING EMPLOYED FOR
THREE YEARS DOES NOT GUARANTEE
SUFFICIENT PATIENT SAFETY AND
TRAINING. SO WE'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT. WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SECTION AS IT
RELATES TO THE USAGE OF THE TUM
DOCTOR AND THE REST OF THE BILL,
AS IT GOES WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS. WE'LL CONTINUE TO
REVIEW THEM AND WEIGH IN WITH
EVERYONE. BUT THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME, I CAN HAVE
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION, DON SHINSKY, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF DERMATOLOGY AND DERMATOLOGIC
SURGERY, WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMEND AS OF TODAY. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO MORE COLLEAGUES. BRING
IT BACK. ANY QUESTIONS? THERE'S
A MOTION BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
MADAM CHAIR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I KNOW YOU GUYS KNOW
THESE OMNIBUS BILLS ARE HARD.
THEY'RE FULL OF A LOT OF THINGS.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE. AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR HELP. THE
MOTION IS MOVED BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. A MOTION IS DUE. PASS
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ASHBY AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
WHEN I WHEN I ALVARADO. GIL.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA. I
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER. DODD
DODD. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER LASER. AYE. MENGIBAR.
NILO. AYE. NILO AYE. ROTH. ROTH
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK
THERE'S NINE VOTES TO GET OUT,
BUT WE'LL KEEP THE ROLL CALL
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME. MADAM CHAIR, WE WILL MOVE
ON TO SB 1453. GREAT. THANK YOU.
SB 1453 IS THE DENTAL BOARD.
SUNSET BILL GOT A COUPLE OF
WITNESSES. I THINK, WITHOUT
LEGISLATION, THE BOARD EXPIRES
ON JANUARY 1ST, 2025. OBVIOUSLY
WE DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
THE BILL WILL BE AMENDED
FOLLOWING TODAY'S HEARING TO
REFLECT SOME NECESSARY CHANGES
STEMMING FROM THE SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT DISCUSSIONS THAT
OCCURRED. SB 1453 WILL EXTEND
THE BOARD FOR FOUR YEARS,
PROVIDE EXPANDED CARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DENTAL
ASSISTANTS, CLARIFY PROVISIONS
RELATED TO PEDIATRIC SEDATION,
MAKE NECESSARY CHANGES TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT SENATOR GLAZER'S SB
501, AND MAKE VARIOUS OTHER
UPDATES TO THE DENTAL PRACTICE
ACT. WITH ME TODAY IS TRACY
MONTES, WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE DENTAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING, VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, AGAIN, I AM
TRACY MONTES, EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
ON BEHALF OF THE DENTAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE BOARD
SUPPORTS ITS EXTENSION OF THE
SUNSET DATE AS WELL AS THE 12
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL. WE WERE
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THAT MOVING
FORWARD FOR CONSIDERATION, AND
THEN THE BOARD OBVIOUSLY WILL BE
REVIEWING THE FULL BILL AT ITS
MAY 14TH AND 15TH MEETING. AND
WE JUST WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR ASHBY FOR EXTENDING THE
SUNSET DATE AND WORKING WITH US.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER LEADS
, WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, ANY
INDIVIDUAL WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD AND STATE Ã SUPPORT
SEEING NONE. ANY LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SORRY, WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION. JESSICA MORAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE IN SUPPORT
AND APPRECIATIVE OF THE LANGUAGE
INVOLVING A DENTAL ASSISTING
PATHWAYS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE.
COLLEAGUES THERE IS A MOTION BY
SENATOR GLAZER. MADAM CHAIR,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? URGENT.
AYE. VOTE. THANK YOU. MY BEST
ONE YET. THIS IS SORRY. THE
MOTION IS, MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZER. THE MOTION IS DO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL ROLL. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. WHEN I NGUYEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER. DODD. DODD AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. MENGIBAR NILO. AYE. NILO.
AYE. ROTH. ROTH AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK. THERE'S NINE VOTES
TO GET THE BILL OUT, BUT WE WILL
LEAVE THE CALL OPEN, WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO SB 1455. MADAM CHAIR,
PLEASE PROCEED. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, 1455 IS THE
CONTRACTOR STATE LICENSE BOARD.
SUNSET EXTENSION BILL. IT
ADDRESSES ISSUES DISCUSSED
DURING THE SUNSET REVIEW HEARING
ON THAT SUBJECT MATTER, AND
INCLUDES ALSO INFORMATION SHARED
IN THE SUNSET REVIEW REPORT AND
THE COMMITTEE SUNSET REVIEW
BACKGROUND PAPER FOR THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE OPERATIONS OF THE
LICENSE BOARD AND ITS AUTHORITY
TO APPOINT A REGISTRAR OF
CONTRACTORS BY FOUR YEARS,
TAKING US TO JANUARY 1ST, 2029.
IT ALSO MAKES CHANGES TO THE
EXAM FEE SCHEDULE, ALLOWING A
LICENSE APPLICANT TO PAY THE
EXAM PROVIDER DIRECTLY.
ADDITIONALLY, SB 1455
ESTABLISHES A ROUTE FOR
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA TO BECOME LICENSED
CONTRACTORS. THIS IS IN LINE
WITH THE AUTHORITY PROVIDED BY
SB 1454 FOR THE BUREAU OF
SECURITY AND INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES, WHICH WAS APPROVED BY
THIS COMMITTEE LAST WEEK. THIS
BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE LICENSE
BOARD TO RECOUP ENFORCEMENT
EXPENSES WHEN IT MUST USE AN
INDUSTRY EXPERT TO REVIEW AND
ASSESS CONSUMER COMPLAINTS. IT
CLARIFIES THAT AN AWARDING
AUTHORITY FOR A PUBLIC CONTRACT
MUST ABIDE BY THE CURRENT
CLASSIFICATION UNDER THE
CONTRACTOR'S STATE LICENSE LAW.
LASTLY, THIS BILL PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL TWO YEAR DELAY FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL CONTRACTORS,
REGARDLESS OF EMPLOYEE STATUS,
TO OBTAIN WORKERS COMPENSATION
COVERAGE. I DO PLAN TO AMEND THE
BILL TO REQUIRE THE LICENSE
BOARD TO CREATE CRITERIA WHICH
WOULD ALLOW FOR THOSE LICENSEES
WHO HAVE NO EMPLOYEES TO BE
EXEMPT FROM THE WORKER'S
COMPENSATION REQUIREMENT. PRIOR
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 216.
THE DELAY GIVES US A LITTLE MORE
TIME TO DO THAT. THE CHANGE IS
IN THIS BILL AIM TO IMPROVE THE
OVERALL OPERATIONS OF THE
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE BOARD AND
ENSURE A HEALTHY AND EFFICIENT
CONTRACT WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA
. I KNOW THERE WERE OTHER ISSUES
RAISED IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER,
AND I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS,
AS IS OUR COMMITTEE, AS ALWAYS.
AND I KNOW MY ASSEMBLY, BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COLLEAGUES WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THESE ISSUES
WITH US AS WELL. TODAY WE HAVE
WITH US. MIKE, I HAVE NO IDEA
HOW TO SAY YOUR LAST NAME FROM
THE CONTRACT STATE LICENSE
BOARD, AND HE'LL ANSWER ALL YOUR
HARD QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING,
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MIKE JANETZKI FOR THE
CONTRACTOR LICENSE BOARD, THE
BOARD IS IN SUPPORT OF SB 1455,
WHICH DOES EXTEND THE BOARD FOR
ANOTHER FOUR YEARS SO THAT IT
MAY CONTINUE TO FULFILL ITS
CONSUMER PROTECTION MANDATE AND
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. THE
BILL ALSO DOES ADDRESS SEVERAL
IMPORTANT NEW ISSUES RAISED BY
THE BOARD IN ITS SUNSET REPORT,
WHICH IN PRINT CURRENTLY DOES
INCLUDE, THE SOME OF THE ITEMS
ALREADY MENTIONED BY THE
HONORABLE CHAIR. THE PATHWAY TO
LICENSURE FOR TRIBES,
EXAMINATION ADMINISTRATION FEES
TO BE COLLECTED AT COST BY THE
EXAMINATION VENDOR, AS WELL AS
RECOUPING COSTS TO CSLB OF
INDUSTRY EXPERT INSPECTIONS IN
APPROPRIATE CASES. THE BOARD
DOES LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
ITS WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
ANY TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF ANY
EXISTING LANGUAGE OR ANY NEW
FORTHCOMING LANGUAGE, ALSO,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE,
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD WORK, ON
THIS MEASURE AND THE SUNSET
PROCESS WITH THAT, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. AND
BACK TO THE VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME, ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
STAY IN SUPPORT, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. HI, ALEX RIVERA WITH
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS, PARTICULARLY
THE ISSUANCE OF LICENSES TO
TRIBES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO STAY IN OPPOSITION
. THÀNH SEEING NONE. BRING IT
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS
AND MOTIONS. THERE'S A MOTION BY
SENATOR ROTH. MADAM CHAIR, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? URGENT I
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT THIS.
THAT DOWN PRETTY GOOD. GETTING
GOOD AT THAT PART. THAT LINE,
THE MOTION, HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ROTH. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ASHBY. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
WHEN I WHEN I ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA I
ARCHULETA. AYE BECKER. DODD.
DODD. AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. LAZAR. AYE. MENGIBAR
NILO. AYE. NILO. AYE. ROTH ROTH
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK
THERE'S NINE VOTES, BUT WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLL CALL OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS. MADAM CHAIR,
PLEASE. AT THIS TIME, WE'LL MOVE
TO SB 1456. ALL RIGHT. LAST ONE,
COLLEAGUES, SB 1456, I THINK WE
DO HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR
THOUGH. BUT THIS IS MY LAST ONE
HERE. ALL RIGHT. SB 1456 IS THE
SUNSET BILL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ATHLETIC COMMISSION. THE
COMMISSION EXPIRES ON JANUARY
ONE, 2025. THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMISSION CAN CONTINUE TO
OPERATE AND DO ITS MISSION
CRITICAL WORK PROTECTING THE
HEALTH, SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BOXERS AND MIXED
MARTIAL ARTS ATHLETES. THE BILL
WILL BE AMENDED FOLLOWING
TODAY'S HEARING TO REFLECT
NECESSARY CHANGES STEMMING FROM
THE SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
DISCUSSION THAT YOU ALL
PARTICIPATED IN EARLIER THIS
YEAR. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, SEEING NONE ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
STAY A SUPPORT POSITION. ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
ANY INDIVIDUAL WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE AS WELL? SEEING NONE.
COLLEAGUES. THE BILL SENATOR
ROTH, THE BILL'S MOTION BY
SENATOR ROTH, SENATOR Ó, THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE URGENT. I VOTE ONE MORE
TIME. THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ROTH. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATION. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. WHEN
I WHEN I ALVARADO. GIL.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA I
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER. DODD
DODD. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GLASER. LASER I MENGIBAR. NILO I
NILO I ROTH ROTH I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK. OKAY, THAT'S NINE
TO NONE. WE BILL GETS OUT. BUT
OF COURSE WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ANOTHER MOMENT HERE. SO WE
CAN CALL THE ROLL IN A IN A
MINUTE FOR OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
AREN'T HERE. I THINK WE DO HAVE
A CONSENT AGENDA HERE. SO WE'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO NEED A MOTION
FOR THAT. WAY TO GO, SENATOR
DODD. OUT IN FRONT. THERE WE GO.
SENATOR DODD MOVES CONSENT. CALL
THE ROLL SB 1526. ASHBY AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GIL. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA AYE.
BECKER. DODD. DODD. AYE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER LAZER. AYE.
MENGIBAR. NILO. AYE. NEAL. AYE
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK. NINE ALSO. ALL
RIGHT. NINE ZERO. THAT IS ALSO
OUT. BUT WE WILL PUT IT ON CALL.
GIVE ME JUST 1192.
ALL RIGHT. I'M GONNA TAKE A PAGE
FROM SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES BOOK
HERE. AND NOTE TO ANY SENATORS
WHO ARE IN THE BUILDING. NOW
WOULD BE THE TIME TO COME DOWN.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE ROLL, BECAUSE MOST OF THE
COMMITTEE IS HERE AND THERE ARE
A FEW OF YOU WHO WOULD STILL
NEED TO VOTE ON A COUPLE OF THE
EARLIER ITEMS. SO LET'S TAKE UP
ITEM ONE. FIRST. SENATOR
BRADFORD, WHICH RIGHT NOW SITS
AT 7 TO 0. MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. WHEN ALVARADO. GIL
ALVARADO GIL I DODD DODD I.
GLASER. GLASER I MENGIBAR. WILK
NINE ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON.
CALL. OKAY. ITEM NUMBER TWO, SB
1064. MOTION DOES DO. PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE 6 TO 0 WITH CHAIR
VOTING AYE. THIS IS SENATOR
LAIRD'S BILL. YOU GUYS OKAY?
WHEN ON ALVARADO, GIL ALVARADO.
GIL, I DODD DODD I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GLASER. GLASER I
MENGIBAR WILK. OKAY, THAT'S TEN
ZERO. ENOUGH TO GET OUT, BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
ANOTHER MOMENT. HERE. WE'LL GO
TO ITEM THREE. THIS IS SENATOR
DROSSOS SB 1490. IT SITS AT FIVE
ZERO RIGHT NOW. WISHES DO PASSES
A MINUTE TO THE SENATE FLOOR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. WHEN
ALVARADO GIL. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. DODD. AYE DODD. AYE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER
GLASER. AYE. MENGIBAR. NILO.
WILK OKAY, THAT'S NINE ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FOUR, WHICH IS SENATOR
ROTH'S SB 1042, WHICH SITS AT
SEVEN ZERO RIGHT NOW. OKAY.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER DODD DODD. AYE GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. MENGIBAR NILO. WILK
SO THAT'S NINE ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON. CALL FOR ITEM FIVE. THIS
IS SENATOR DODD'S SB 1071, WHICH
SITS AT NINE RIGHT NOW. THE
QUESTION IS, DO PASSES AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER LASER. LASER EYE MENGIBAR
WILK. THANK YOU. KATZ AT TEN.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL NEXT
ITEM SIX. SENATOR WILKES, SB
1233, SITTING AT EIGHT VOTES
RIGHT NOW. MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. BECKER LASER. LASER EYE.
MENGIBAR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK. THAT
MOVES TO TEN ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON. CALL FILE ITEM SEVEN.
SENATOR WINS. SB 1459 HAS NINE
VOTES IN FAVOR RIGHT NOW. NONE
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY, MOTION IS
DO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER MENGIBAR. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
TEN ZERO. WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
MOVE TO FILE ITEM EIGHT, ALSO BY
SENATOR NGUYEN SB 1478 SITTING
WITH EIGHT VOTES. RIGHT NOW.
MOTION IS DO PASS SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER. GLASER. LASER EYE.
MENGIBAR. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK. ALL
RIGHT. THAT HAS TEN. WILL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NINE, WHICH IS
AUTHORED BY ME. BUT ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMITTEE, SB 1451, OUR
OMNIBUS BILL. I'M NOT SURE. I
THINK IT HAS NINE VOTES RIGHT
NOW. MOTION DOES DO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER MENGIBAR. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
I WILK I CGRTS 11. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON. CALL MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TEN, ALSO AUTHORED BY ME. BUT ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS
THE DENTISTRY BILL, SB 1453 I
BELIEVE ALSO HAS NINE VOTES
RIGHT NOW A MOTION IS DO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER MENGIBAR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
I WILK I OKAY. THAT'S 11. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL FILE ITEM
NUMBER 11 WHICH IS ALSO AUTHORED
BY ME. THIS IS ANOTHER COMMITTEE
BILL, SB 1455 HAS NINE VOTES.
QUESTION IS DO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER MENGIBAR. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
I WILK I THAT'S 11. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON. CALL AND GO TO THE NEXT
ITEM. FILE ITEM 12 SB 1456.
ANOTHER COMMITTEE BILL ON THE
STATE ATHLETIC COMMISSION HAS
NINE VOTES. MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. BECKER I
BECKER I MENGIBAR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I WILK
HI WILK I ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS
12. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL AND
MOVE TO CONSENT WHICH IS FILED
ITEM 13 SB 1526 VOTES ARE 9 TO
0. BECKER. BECKER I MENGIBAR.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK I WILK I. ALL
RIGHT, THAT'S 12. WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON CALL. THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE. I'M GOING
TO WAIT FOR JUST A SECOND.
SENATOR BECKER. NO. YOU'RE FINE.
I JUST
.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THIS ROLL ONE MORE TIME FOR THE
THREE OF YOU WHO ARE HERE. THIS
IS GOING TO BE OUR LAST TIME
THROUGH THE ROLL, SO HOPEFULLY
WE'VE GOT EVERYBODY WHO HOPED TO
CAST A VOTE IN BUSINESS,
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TODAY. LET'S START
OFF WITH FILE ITEM ONE. SB 1059
FOR SENATOR BRADFORD, WHICH
CURRENTLY HAS NINE VOTES AND IS
HEADED TO A PROPS OKAY. CHAIR
VOTING AYE WHEN MENGIBAR WILK Ã
WILK I OKAY, THAT'S TEN ZERO.
THE BILL IS OUT. ITEM TWO
SENATOR LAIRD'S SB 1064 HAS TEN
VOTES AND IS HEADED TO A PROP.
SORRY CHAIR VOTING AYE WHEN
MENGIBAR WILK I OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S 11. THAT BILL IS OUT AT
FILE ITEM THREE. SENATOR DROSSOS
SB 40 TÍNH 90 HAS NINE VOTES IN
FAVOR. NONE. OPPOSE IS ALSO
HEADED TO A PROPS CHAIR VOTING
AYE WHEN MENGIBAR NILO WILK NOT
VOTING. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL HAS NINE VOTES AND IS OUT.
FILE ITEM FOUR. SENATOR ROTH'S
SB 1042 CURRENTLY HAS NINE VOTES
AND IS HEADED TO A PROPS. CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. I MENGIBAR NILO.
WILK. HI. WILK. AYE ALL RIGHT.
11. THAT BILL IS OUT NEXT UP,
FILE ITEM FIVE. SENATOR DODD'S
1071, SB 1071 CURRENTLY HAS TEN
I VOTES. NO. NOS. HEADED TO A
PROPS CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING. AYE. BECKER I BECKER I
MENGIBAR WILK. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
12 VOTES. THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE
ITEM SIX, THIS IS SENATOR
WILK'S. SB 1233, ABLY PRESENTED
BY SENATOR NILO IN SENATOR
WILKES ABSENCE, HAS TEN VOTES
ALREADY. NO NOS HEADED TO
PROBES. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING. AYE. BECKER. I BECKER I
MENGIBAR WILK. NO WILK WILK. I
ALL RIGHT, THAT'S 12, 12, 12
VOTES. THAT BILL IS OUT WITH ITS
AUTHOR'S VOTE. EXCELLENT WORK.
ALL RIGHT. FILE ITEM SEVEN.
SENATOR WINS SB 1459. THIS HAS
TEN VOTES AND IS ALSO HEADED TO
A PROPS CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING. AYE. BECKER. BECKER I
MENGIBAR WILK I WILK I. ALL
RIGHT 12 VOTES THAT ONE GETS
OUT. FILE ITEM EIGHT SB 1478,
ALSO BY SENATOR NGUYEN HAS TEN
VOTES AND IS HEADED TO A PROPS
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER. BECKER I MENGIBAR WILK
WILK I 12. THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NINE. THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE'S OMNIBUS BILL. SB
1451 HAS 11 VOTES. CURRENTLY NO
OPPOSITION. BECKER. BECKER I
MENGIBAR. ALL RIGHT. THAT'S 12.
THAT BILL GETS OUT ALSO A
COMMITTEE BILL SB 1453 HAS 11
VOTES IS HEADED TO A PROPS NEXT
BECKER. BECKER A MENGIBAR. ALL
RIGHT 12 VOTES. THAT ONE IS OUT.
ITEM 11 SB 1455. ALSO, A
COMMITTEE BILL HAS 11 VOTES. NO
VOTES AGAINST BECKER. BECKER I
MENGIBAR OKAY. ALL RIGHT. 12.
THAT IS OUT AS WELL. FILE ITEM
12 SB 1456. THIS IS THE FINAL
COMMITTEE BILL HERE THAT WAS
HEARD TODAY ON STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION HAS 12 VOTES HEADED
TO A PROPS MENGIBAR. THAT ONE'S
OUT 12 TO NOTHING. AND THEN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SB 1526 ONE
LAST TIME HAS 12 VOTES HEADED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MENGIBAR OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, 12 VOTES. THAT ONE'S
OUT. WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THIS
HEARING. THANK YOU. CHAIR. YEAH.
THANK YOU